All right.
People.
We are alive on the youtube.
We're live streaming.
We lost our live streaming capabilities a couple of days ago.
We don't know why.
I don't have an email address of anyone at youtube.
I look forward to getting one one day.
Uh,
but apparently we're live right now and I'm with,
Whoa,
Mr Twitter,
Mr Twitter.
That's what I just tweet out.
I called him mister Twitter after what happened on Rogan.
Ya'll.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm calling you missed your Twitter Tim pool.
It was crazy for me after,
you know,
five,
I'm assuming everybody knows that I was on with Jack and Joe and for me,
I'm just having a conversation,
like the cameras don't exist.
I'm sitting here listening with the to say I'm trying to be respectful and make
sure they finish their point,
not let them go too far with it.
Because there are a few times where I was like,
you can't say you're lying.
But after the fact,
all these videos were like Tim pool destroys,
you know?
And I'm like,
I didn't feel like I was destroying them.
I just felt like we're having a conversation,
you know?
Yeah,
I felt like they were listening.
At least Jack was Tim.
This is the Internet.
Yeah.
If you even engage in a remotely decent conversation with someone,
someone gets that is,
hey Ruben just destroyed temple.
There will be several districts here.
Okay.
So you were on with,
uh,
with Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey,
who most people know,
and he was on a rogue in about a month ago.
He's been in Sam Harris' podcast and a bunch of others.
He agreed to do this show two years ago.
I've emailed him a zillion times and I tweet at,
yeah,
I saw it.
Yep.
Oh,
they're trying to clear the schedule and I,
he is welcome.
He would've been welcome here today and all that.
Uh,
you were also on with Vijaya got a yeah.
who is from legal and trust and safety at Twitter.
So it was the two of them Rogan sort of moderating it.
And you're kind of brought in,
well,
the brought in as the muscle basically to,
I mean,
you can kind of sit back and,
and you to just go to town on that checkpoint.
His lawyer.
Yeah.
You know,
and,
and Joe,
Barbara got a bunch of good points but I think my favorite meme,
which,
which described what happened was it's,
it shows that Ash Ketchum and Gary from Pokemon with two Pokemon underneath with
my name and Vaginas name under it.
Like they brought us both in to like get to the nitty gritty cause I,
you know,
here's the thing,
uh,
in the first interview that Joe did,
Joe didn't know a lot and uh,
neither did jack.
Uh,
and I think,
I think it's fair to point out jack was running a ton of companies and I respect
him for going on at numerous times,
but I think it's important to point out most of the questions I asked he defer
to,
you know,
trust and safety.
Yeah.
So,
all right,
so let's just do a whole bunch of stuff here.
So I want to ask you,
the first thing that I'm going to ask you is just how did this whole freaking
thing come together?
Cause I was,
I was buying dog food yesterday and then I suddenly saw a pop up and I was like,
how the hell is this happening?
Yeah,
no,
I knew you were coming in here and I had no idea that it was going on.
So I want to ask you that,
but I just want to say one thing quick off the bat,
which is what you just said there,
hits it on the head that it will all I saw out of the two of them,
uh,
but mostly Jack and I don't mean this to attack him or her personally.
I mean as professionals doing the job they doing at Twitter.
If you're going to go on shows and talk about these things,
that all it was was endless kicking the can down the road that you know,
Harry Truman,
the buck stops here.
I mean there's no,
there's no bucket and there is no stop.
It's like,
we'll look into it.
Oh that happened.
We're not sure about that.
We'll talk about it with this person.
There's just,
it's just endless.
Two important things came out of that conversation regardless of anything else
was when,
uh,
in two different instances I pointed out if your rule,
so,
so the way I described it on Twitter as to a conservative mis-gendering,
someone would be,
if they are biologically male and you called them a female pronoun and to
progressive's it's in the,
it's the inverse.
If a trans woman wants use the Pronoun,
I pointed that out.
One of those is factually correct.
We should make a point about that.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
One of them is actually on Wikipedia consensus for the rest of society that it
is factually true.
But the,
the point I want to make is not whether or not your ideology ideology is correct
or not correct,
but that you do enforce an ideological rule.
And she said thank you for the feedback and then Joe and which,
which she,
she,
but then gentleman at another point and then her response was,
I think that's absolutely correct.
Show.
So I'm,
I'm glad that they admitted they do have a bias.
And they were a few points where I saw jack have a look on his face.
So the first thing was when they were pointing out their rules,
I interjected by saying,
no,
you're,
you actually have a rule that's biased against conservatives.
And Jack had this look where it was like,
what,
what rule?
Like he didn't realize it.
He didn't,
he didn't.
I'm like,
you realize one of the top podcasts in the world,
Ben Shapiro's show and Ben Shapiro disagrees with you to tens of millions or
more.
They don't agree with that rule.
It makes no sense to them.
And then I,
you know,
I tried to make a point about,
uh,
I looked it up,
it's called body integrity identity disorder.
Is there people who like amputate body parts?
I'm not trying to equate the two,
but to point out there are other similar syndromes that aren't protected under
the rules.
So they do have the specific predicted class based on an ideology.
So there was a ton of moments like that where it seemed like you were laying out
some pretty clear things that again,
they couldn't,
they sort of were kind of evasive or we don't know where we'll look into it,
right?
Like it's a lot of,
we'll look into it and it's like,
all right,
we know you're not really gonna look into it because this,
it's not as if this,
it's not as if Tim pool as much as I respect to him pull just magically came up
with all this stuff yesterday,
right?
Like this stuff's been out there for awhile.
It looks like the tweet I referenced has gone.
Uh,
I,
so I,
I specifically prepared this,
I don't want to call it a stunt,
but I was like,
I want to be able to pull this up on cue.
So I set up a bitly link to this tweet in question from September.
That was doxing.
Law enforcement never taken down and people were tweeting,
Jack,
what's up with this?
There's articles written about how it's never come down.
And what they said is that they took down some of the people that linked to the
tweet or something,
but no,
no.
She just said,
oh,
I don't know.
I don't,
you know,
we,
we make mistakes and,
and you know,
uh,
I will say this too,
after the show,
Jack said my two analogies about sand and snow were really,
really important.
And he's going to,
he understands what I signed by this and that references if they keep making
mistakes.
The analogy I always use is how many grains of sand until you have a heap.
The heat being biased against conservatives and the snowflake references
Twitter.
Thanks.
Look,
we're just one company.
We're making mistakes.
They don't themselves for the fact that all of these other companies are doing
the same thing.
It's an avalanche.
And they're,
they're one of the snowflakes.
The only way you change this is when the individuals and the company is take
responsibility for what's happening.
Do you,
all right,
so hold on.
I don't want to lose the question about how the hell this thing came to be.
It's funny to run off that road at this point yet.
Do you think they actually care?
Jack Link's partly silk.
So,
all right,
well you were the one sitting across from you,
so I wanna know.
I want to know your thoughts on that.
But I partly was just like,
these guys know exactly what they're doing.
We know that conservatives get banned and shadow banned and unfollowed and all
these things all,
and it's not just conservatives by the way,
cause it's people like [inaudible] is not a conservative.
Right,
right,
exactly.
Yeah.
So,
but that basically they go on these shows,
even though it was sort of impressive that the legal person showed up that
they're just going on just again to kick the can down the road.
Cause he gives a glimmer of hope for people to be like,
see they care.
They're kind of doing their thing,
even though we know nothing's going to change.
Right.
And that's exactly how I ended it.
I'm like,
here I am sitting here,
Jack,
you're justifying why everything you're doing is right.
I'm trying to justify what you're doing is wrong.
And that's the end.
That's nothing's going to change.
And so,
so for me,
I'm looking at the,
the,
the opening gateway,
the bridge to the nightmare dystopia.
When I see conservatives being banned from bank accounts from Patriot is one
thing,
but that paypal another than chase actually has people done mastercard,
you know,
according to Patriot,
mastercard actually wanting to get Robert,
I grew up,
I believe Robert Spencer and I'm like,
this is happening.
You realize that,
right?
Real China's doing it on a grand scale and we're watching the,
the start of it,
the avalanche is kicking off.
And these companies like,
I don't want to,
you know,
none of the other companies will showed up,
but Twitter is going,
we're doing,
we're doing our best.
Jack outlined this vision of a future to me and he was,
and I'm like,
you're describing the opposite direction to where you're going.
He's,
you know,
like,
uh,
I can remember exactly what I'm saying,
but he was talking about open,
you know,
everyone can speak and all these things and just laying out the four principles
of what makes healthy conversation.
And I'm like,
you realize you're actually walking away from what you're describing.
And you know,
I will say this too.
Um,
ultimately what I feel like was kind of happening is,
is that you tell utilitarian verses deontological debate,
which a,
for those who aren't familiar,
Jack was convinced that he must do the most good.
That means some,
he's looking at the collective and saying,
how can I make sure that 90% out of a,
you know,
a hundred people are sharing their thoughts and I look at this and say,
the individual needs to be allowed to speak.
So out of out of 100 people,
I'm like,
each individual needs to be able to speak and we can't do,
we can't protect everybody.
And that's why I asked Jack when he said,
we did research and that's why we implemented this trans rule.
I said,
why did you stop there?
What?
He said he didn't.
And I'm like,
but look,
if you're going to implement the rule to protect one class of people,
we can look at suicide rates for dentists.
We can look at suicide rates.
Where police,
are you going to make police a protected class or,
or if you're saying,
okay,
well you can't Miss Gender Trans people,
well can you call Jews Nazis?
As I got called a Nazi by several guards,
offensive I think to verified people today and I,
I tweeted,
yeah,
and I don't care.
I mean,
not like that's the fun bit.
Right.
So I get it because if you're,
if you're basically a functioning human being that is in a hysterical nutbag
right.
Exact,
Like basically I don't run around reporting everybody,
I call it out occasionally and I'm only doing it to show the double standard,
not to get these people kicked off.
And it's an action.
Yeah.
To just say you are,
you look what you guys are doing.
I mean by any estimation where they laid out yesterday in terms of targeted
harassment,
that that'll get you booted and the whole Milo thing and we can get into that.
Well,
these people that today there were two verified people calling us fascists and
Nazi's in a bunch of others and that then that harassment escalates to extreme
degrees.
Yeah.
And there are certain personalities that I don't want to name that have made
fake videos and gotten people banned because of it.
Yeah.
So the challenge and calling out the specifics is that they want attention.
And then when you named them,
they point the finger,
I have no problem calling out like organizations,
like I mentioned the SPLC and hope not hate and I'm doing it again.
I know that's going to lead to,
but uh,
you mean the southern poverty hates it,
right?
Oh,
whatever you want to call it.
Yeah,
I'll try.
I'll try to.
It's SPHC is that now?
I don't,
I'm,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna try and be,
I'll call them out for the areas,
but I won't do,
I won't do ride like calling insulted their name or anything.
Yeah,
no,
they're horrible.
I think they're bad.
Simple.
But I will say this,
the only thing I can really say in terms of my personal interaction with them is
that they brought this article that claimed I was attending a Holocaust deniers
conference in Iran and they used a holocaust denying conspiracy theory website
to prove it.
If that's their standard of proof,
that's nightmarish,
especially when they are consulting certain groups or they're involved with
change the terms that org which wants to,
you know,
do all these things.
They did retract that though and they apologized and called me an individual on
the left.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
There you go.
Right.
Well that's all I show much there.
I mean,
module where I had to sue them to get them off his anti Muslim extreme.
Well what he did,
but Muslim,
but here's the,
here's the important thing.
They settled based on a strongly worded letter.
I don't believe it ever actually got to the point where a suit was filed.
So,
uh,
they,
they recognized,
they overstepped their boundaries.
In my case and Magic's case,
there are a lot of people that don't get that same that you know,
uh,
I,
I'm,
I'm not as big as Magid or,
or even you,
but I'm fortunate enough to at least have some,
you know,
notoriety that provides me with protection like t to,
to try and call me right is the most insane thing ever.
And then the weird thing is it's white progressives doing it.
Like my,
my mixed race family who had racist sexually attack us and the white
progressives who are well off are the ones who are pointing the finger at me.
It's like you people are racist.
That's how I can say,
well that that is the new pernicious racism of the left.
But okay,
let's pause for just [inaudible] we're going,
let's get back to the beginning.
How the hell did this thing even happen?
Because when I saw it,
I'm sitting in the parking lot at Petco and I was like well cause cause it's
like if you,
if they were trying to protect their asses,
it's like the last person you'd want to sit in there with is you.
Because if you would've said to me,
who's the right guy to take them down a notch,
I would've said you,
there might've been a couple of other guys,
but I'm,
you'd be right in the center of the right person that gets all of this.
I feel lucky,
but who walk on?
How the hell did this?
It's a long,
it's a decently,
it's not super long,
but,
so here's what happens.
Uh,
Joe Rogan does the video with pot,
with Jack Dorsey.
They get slammed.
Yeah.
I make a video about it saying like,
I watched the podcast,
I was excited at first it quickly got boring and then I kind of just trailed off
and felt like Joe wasn't actually getting into anything.
And you know,
we're better off for him doing the interview by I'm tiny degree.
But ultimately I don't think we gained anything from it.
Uh,
basically because he didn't get into the nitty gritty.
Yeah,
it was really it.
He goes yo by any,
no,
but he knows this,
right?
It was,
it was a really surface level regurgitation of what we had already heard a
million times.
And so when Joe responded to the complaints,
yeah,
I made a followup video where I was like,
I respect you for doing this.
Joe Recognizes he's gonna,
you know,
I criticize a bunch.
I before the video I made went live because this was just like I make rent
videos on my second channel that they do way better than my more like structured
videos.
But,
uh,
before we even went live,
I got notification that Joe Rogan or somebody's fully with him had copyright
flagged it and I was like,
wait,
Whoa,
hold on.
This is a credit.
This is fair use.
So fortunately,
uh,
several months ago Joe had followed me on Twitter and apologize for,
you know,
he canceled on me in the past and he was just like,
I feel bad about it and it's,
it's,
it's a long time ago.
So now,
now he's following me.
I just tweeted at him and I said,
hey,
would you mind releasing this?
It's fair use.
I was criticizing your podcast.
And he's like,
yeah,
send me the link and we'll go over it.
I sent him the link and then he responds right away with like,
hey man,
your criticisms were actually really good.
Can I call you right now?
And I was like,
sure,
great.
And then he calls me and then he kinda just explained like he felt really bad
that he didn't do a good enough job.
He didn't realize how important these issues work.
He just thought he was meeting with like a tech CEO and he didn't really follow
a lot of this stuff.
And then at the end of the,
that near the end of the call,
we talked for a while.
He goes,
you know,
I owe you coming out on the show man,
so I'll bring you out sometime.
I'm like,
yeah,
sure.
Have a good day.
Five hours later,
whatever.
I'm looking at my shorts playing video games like end of the day,
but to go to bed and my phone rings and it's Joe and he goes,
you want to come on the show on Friday?
And I'm like,
that's like I got to fly tomorrow.
That's like one day.
He's like,
yeah.
And I'm like,
okay.
We go.
I go on the show,
everybody saw it.
It was great.
And then immediately after the show,
he's like,
he calls me up right when I get back to my hotel and he says,
how would you like to come on and do this thing?
Don't tell anybody and it'll be you,
me,
Jack,
and he's going to bring on somebody.
And he says,
I'm trying to confirm it.
So I think the main reason he didn't want to promote it was he was concerned
that like,
it's hard to confirm.
It's,
it's especially with someone as busy as Jacquez.
So he was like,
I want to make,
I don't want to hype it up.
I want to make sure we actually do it.
Otherwise everyone's gonna get angry when we cancel.
So then I didn't know what was gonna happen.
And it wasn't until like a few days ago where he,
uh,
not,
not to be it.
Maybe,
maybe like a week ago,
they were like,
we're good to go.
We're going to fly you out.
And he was like,
I don't think there was anything.
I expressly like don't promote it,
but just Joe was like,
I'm going to,
I'm going to take care of that.
I'm like,
all right.
So I just didn't say anything cause I don't know if was gonna happen.
Right.
So that's why I think it's so,
it's so interesting cause hey,
first off I give Joe Credit for going,
okay,
this isn't my area of expertise per se.
So let me bring in somebody that is so that there's a little bit of that back
and forth,
but be,
it partly brings me back to what I said before,
which is once they had heard,
I don't know when they found out that they,
that you know,
Jack and a and that she backed in,
apparently he pitched to them in advance.
Okay.
So a couple of let's say a couple of days before.
No,
no,
no.
Like a month.
Okay.
So a month.
So they don't the lead time,
no way that this Tim pool guy is going to be the one sitting across from them.
That it seems to me that the only reason that they would agree to do it because
they had to assume it was going to go exactly as it went,
not well for them now is that it would,
the only reason you do it is if it's just to kick the can down the road.
That it's just,
you know what I mean?
It's not for justification.
Yeah.
I mean,
you could look at a vagina,
had a laptop with a bunch of research and,
and I,
I there,
there were a couple instances where I said,
oh,
she makes a good point.
Right?
There are some people she mentioned,
this is why we banned them.
And in some cases,
you know,
I bought up,
sorry of a cod.
I didn't bring him.
I bought Carl Benjamin.
I didn't bring him up to defend them because I know he tweeted things that it's
like,
dude,
you really pushed buttons but then inadvertently find out.
One of them was a very clearly pointing at their,
they're biased rule set and not actually targeting anybody in any way.
In which case they did ended up,
you know,
false striking him at least one time.
But they did,
they did their research.
A few people.
But ultimately I think one point we got out of that was we're just going to
trust you.
Like you haven't presented this evidence to anybody.
You're saying it now.
But there is an important detail there that,
that I want to stress too is that everything she said about why they banned
people,
those are statements of fact.
And if those aren't real and they can't prove it,
they can be sued for defamation.
So anybody who's now been bounded by Twitter that she mentioned would have their
lawyers going back.
Well,
I'm not saying do anything,
I'm just saying if it,
cause I,
Alex Texted Joe Apparently said that's not true.
Okay,
great.
Well,
they made a statement to fact on his show as to why they took action against you
saying,
Alex Jones did x.
If that's not true,
well now you can file your complaint.
Yeah,
see that's what I think the reason I'm so it's not even frustrated.
I'm actually not frustrated by it.
I'm so like sort of blood Zay about it is because it's like I,
you know,
I had Jack Conti in here,
the Patriot CEO like two years ago and there he was sitting with me telling me,
you know,
we'll never people whispering sweet nothings in your or to convince you.
Right.
And it'll only,
we'll only boot people because of manifest observable behavior [inaudible] here,
mob mob and you can't make this stuff up.
And,
and that's sort of what I,
that was the feeling that I got from this Jack,
Jack Dorsey,
that it's just like,
we'll just say things and it kind of keeps moving things along.
Here's what I think.
And again,
I'm not,
I'm really not impugning him as a person.
I,
I'll take your word for it.
Well,
no.
So,
so there are some conservatives who are not super high,
like high profile,
whatever that um,
I've met in the past and someone told me a long time ago,
not,
not super long ago,
relatively recently,
within the past few months,
that Jack's actually not a bad guy.
It's the people around him who are telling these things and he's not exposed to
herd some insiders though.
Exactly.
And so what ends up happening is when I said,
your rule is biased against conservatives from the get go,
Jack genuinely looked confused and he said,
wait,
what rule?
And then I do explain it to them,
but then maybe he shouldn't be the CEO of the company.
I mean not to be [inaudible] he's the CEO of several companies.
Is that correct?
I believe so,
yeah.
I mean you've got cash app,
square,
Twitter,
I don't know what else.
All right.
So let's just say Twitter is enough of a job in and of itself.
Like if you don't know the rules,
like what are you doing?
Right,
right.
Takes pleasure.
It's not that he didn't know the rules and he didn't because he talked about the
research they did for that role.
It's that he didn't realize more than 50 about 50% of this country.
Actually,
it's way more than that.
Don't agree with that ideological view.
And the reason I say more than that is because moderate liberals,
you know,
like I talked to my mom and my mom is a lifelong liberal and she's,
she's a progressive.
She agrees with so much of what the modern left today agrees with and the new
progressives and,
but she said,
oh,
I don't know if you know,
trans women should be competing against biological women.
And I said,
Whoa,
hold your horses.
Their mom.
That's a conservative,
you know?
Uh,
and so if my mom a liberal is still questioning that,
then Twitter's very clearly taking a very small minority position on that.
If you've got a feminist like Megan Murphy who is clearly on the left being
banned because she doesn't want to adhere to this,
it's not even a left versus right issue.
You've got moderate liberals,
feminists,
conservatives all saying,
we'll hold on on this issue,
but Twitter is clearly adopted a very ideological rule.
And Jack,
I don't think anyone's ever told Jack that.
And here's the thing,
when really don't think that though,
I don't,
I'm with you on all this.
But so he,
so he lives in some level of a bubble.
But of course it's very obvious stuff.
I mean what you just laid out,
I mean I've been talking about this for have you had heavy use now?
You know what I mean?
It's not like,
it's not like the Internet hasn't been like a buzz about this type of
conversation,
but no one's got to him.
I haven't seen anyone actually break down.
They say,
oh,
but hate speech.
That's not fair.
They say things like that.
And I'm like,
no,
no.
Hold on.
There's a very clear ideological divide between this rule and everything else.
When it comes to hate speech,
very obviously conservatives are Gung Ho on free speech and the menu on the left
aren't,
but that's still different because it's like we just don't want you to harass
people and say mean things and it's kind of been normalized because all the
platforms do it.
But the mis-gendering thing is so specific.
Uh,
and,
and you know,
I'll say this too,
I really hate using,
like I,
they kind of backed me into using this because I don't necessarily disagree with
why they have the rule.
Like I think purposefully being disrespectful,
targeting people.
Mis-Gendering deadnaming I don't,
I think those are wrong,
but at the same time you have to recognize conservatives think you're,
it's inverted for them,
right?
They think it's wrong to gender someone.
They're not by luck,
you know,
that's not their biological gender.
And my goal is,
look,
I'm,
uh,
so we talked about this the first time I was here.
I'm a social liberal amount of classical liberal,
but I respect the right of other people to have opinions and debate and share
ideas and try and figure out what.
So I will say,
listen,
this is what they think.
And they're,
and they're arguing and you don't see that.
And I genuinely believe,
because I've seen the debates with the conversations with Jack,
the testimony from Congress,
no one has ever pointed this out to him.
And he was Kinda like,
I think he kind of realized it.
I look at Jack,
I mean that to me that makes it sound like he's an idiot.
I mean,
I like,
I completely hear you and I'm not,
I'm not judging your judgment or him actually.
It's just like,
I don't know what job you're,
and then,
dude,
you should have another job I think.
I think he's,
uh,
it's almost like he has,
say he is the chief executive officer,
but it's,
I think it's more of a,
he gets an email and goes to,
sure.
You know what I mean?
Does that sort of tell you though what social justice does to accompany that?
All this could be going on and you sort of need a head guy.
It's true for any company depending how big it is though.
You know,
it's like Jack can only know so much,
but I also think you have to look at,
um,
I,
I could be wrong on this.
Jack was fired.
They replaced him with Dick Costolo and then take a solo laughed and then Jack
came back.
So it may just be that they were like,
bring them back in.
It's going to be kind of a in paper and like in name only thing.
He does have authority,
obviously he's talked about that,
but I think he's not super focused.
And again,
I'm not attacking the guy.
It's like I want him to come in here and I would treat them with as much respect
as I would of anyone else.
So.
Okay.
Well,
well yeah,
go ahead.
Well,
I think the only reason these conversations happen is because of him.
I think he,
he,
you know,
he follows,
I'm pretty sure he follows Jordan Peterson.
I think he follows you.
Um,
so I think he genuine genuinely is trying to understand why people are mad at
him.
And that's why after the podcast he said the grains of sand thing makes a lot of
sense.
Like to him,
he was probably thinking,
we just,
we just made mistakes,
man.
And then I say,
right,
but each of those mistakes makes a huge pile and people are pointing to the pile
and you're going,
but it's,
it's a mistake.
It's a mistake.
No,
it's a pile,
dude.
It's a huge heap.
It keep doing it.
It's a pretty big heap.
So,
yeah.
Okay.
So when,
so you,
there,
there was a lot of the conversation that was about,
well,
more of this seems to be happening to conservatives,
but you did point out actually that sometimes they've banned some lefty
accounts,
right?
Yeah.
Not,
it's not a lot,
but there,
there have been some,
there's a,
a decent amount of,
so I would say it's the lower tier accounts across the board.
If it's,
it's really freaky to,
it's the anti war left is getting a ton of,
of heat,
but they're not particularly popular or mainstream.
So there's no one coming out to defend them.
Conservatives when they hear about it,
we'll be like,
hey,
that's not cool,
but it's not an,
you know,
so,
so occupy Wall Street accounts have been banned by Twitter for,
for,
I have no idea why they never pushed you to say this got rid of like 56
accounts.
Uh,
some with like 50,000 followers.
So the activist left that are not the same as the editor to like high profile
regressive left people.
These are people predominantly focused on Venezuela and Siri on like get,
you know,
end the war.
They don't have the mainstream pull from the left to defend them.
And the information isn't traveling to conservative circles.
I see it,
you know,
somebody,
uh,
Michelle Malkin tweeted,
you know,
this,
this uh,
silicon valley lobbyists said it happens to the left too,
but couldn't name a single person.
And then I named organizations that have been hit recently.
Uh,
I think it's fair to point out for every one antiwar left us,
you get like 30 conservative.
So that's why I was asking you the question,
cause I don't want people to think that it's nobody on the left because it's not
nobody,
but in terms of proportion it seems to be far worse.
And it's not far right.
I mean that's the thing.
It's not far right now,
it's not Sargon of Akkad.
Benjamin May have broken their rules by targeted harassment or whatever.
What he was saying,
he said some crazy stuff.
Whatever he did,
I'm not sure,
I'm not defending it or whatever,
but it's like the idea that he's far right in my mind is crazy.
Like,
yeah.
Is,
well,
you know,
he's a bit of a troll but he's basically a,
an old school liberal or something on that.
So Argon and Daniella,
they joined Ukip.
Yeah.
And so even though you know,
like Dang,
Kyla has had communist star,
uh,
on his chest and he has political compass is slightly center left.
It's like you join a conservative or right wing party.
Then like,
I don't know how you,
you say you're not to right wing,
but either way,
that in and of itself isn't a reason to get booted off a platform.
Of course not,
but,
but Sargon set a bunch of stuff and he even messaged me,
he was like,
he was saying like,
Oh man,
your face when you realize like what I said,
you know,
it's like you said some,
he said some pretty crazy things,
man.
Yeah.
So do you think it's possible,
I,
I'm sort of coming to this belief that we're about to watch one,
if not more of these giant tech companies completely crumbled within the next
two years that the platforms have grown to the point where nobody can control
them anymore.
And this is where I would give you a little,
I would give Jack,
let's say a little bit of Alicia not understanding what's going on,
but they've all grown so big.
There are so many people on them.
There are so many bots and targeted accounts and all of these things and
competing interests and people who believe in free speech and people who don't.
And you know,
governments like Pakistan who are trying to get Twitter to take down people for
their blasphemy laws.
Yep.
And then Twitter and American company actually does it.
Well,
I don't think they've taken anybody down.
Did they not take anybody down basement?
And I actually agree with Twitter on this one.
They notify you.
Yeah.
So I've seen a lot of conservatives who are upset that has gotten this blasphemy
notice.
And I'm like,
oh,
hold on Twitter.
Send me a favor.
If you could be killed,
if you go to Pakistan now,
if you po,
if you bought violate Pakistan law,
I would appreciate it if Twitter told me,
hey,
just Fyi,
they want to kill you so I don't go there.
Right.
It's just gas.
Twitter hasn't taken any adverse action against these people who have posted
pictures of Muhammad.
They've just said,
we want to let you know,
Pakistan has filed a complaint against you and you may want legal our
presentation to deal with it.
That I agree with that they're giving you a government.
Uh,
notice where we want the transparency in the companies.
It's up.
Those images or whatever images they are,
they are,
those are up in Twitter and Pakistan,
they're taking,
they're taking down in Pakistan,
so they're taking that,
right.
So that's where it's an American company.
See,
this is where I would say an American companies should,
should,
uh,
operate on the laws of America,
in,
um,
in America though,
I mean,
it's,
it's tough.
This is one of the debates too about cultural imperialism should,
and that's one of the things I was asking to,
to Jack,
because I know they enforced blasphemy laws in other countries.
It's,
it's the,
you must follow the laws of the,
of the countries they're in.
But I asked them,
does your hate speech policy apply to Iran?
They pour,
clarified them.
They're blocked in around.
I'm like,
okay,
well what about,
you know,
Pakistan or our country where it's illegal to be gay?
Do will you?
If so,
it's,
it's a weird circumstance.
Yeah.
Let's pull up,
uh,
there's a ton of countries where it's illegal to be gay.
Let's say someone is convicted of sodomy or homosexuality and then you go on
Twitter and target them and say,
you're a dirty criminal,
you're awful.
We'll Twitter ban you because then you have a weird conundrum of the citizen
following the law of his own country being banned by Twitter.
Even though Twitter has to follow the law of that country too.
It's a weird,
now I personally would be on Twitter side on that one,
like that's horrifying what they do in those countries,
but at the same time Twitter is imposing its cultural values on foreign
countries where it's supposed to be following their laws.
It's,
it's,
it's getting to me,
I mean look,
I'm not a CEO of a giant tech company,
but that's where I would just say we're a United States company and we are going
to follow the free speech laws of the United States and if if then the country
wants to stop you from being on there,
well then they can do what they want and they often do as this,
but this is this,
this,
this is why I think we're freedom.
We're going to start saying like a nightmare,
you know,
scenario of dystopia.
What their response to me in how their rules supersede us law is that while
we're a global company,
and I'm like,
right,
but you have a platform that is extremely,
extremely powerful influencing our elections,
and this is the most important point.
People don't seem to understand.
I've seen so much criticism out there out the people out there don't seem to
understand what I'm saying.
They're like,
Tim doesn't understand that free speech doesn't give you a right to a private
platform.
Absolutely.
Right.
Well,
I'm a social liberal who believes in regulation that recognize when a company
becomes so powerful,
it starts becoming a detriment to your democratic republic and your
institutions.
The government must intervene.
That's my opinion.
Yeah.
So you're taking a Trump position on this actually Trump position.
Will Trump launch basically the government to get involved at this point?
Well,
I mean,
I don't,
that's a pretty conservative position.
Mine.
Yeah.
Social socially liberal regulation of major companies.
While it's become conservative now because now you,
it's so weird.
We'll just shows you how things flipped,
right?
Because you hear now conservatives saying it's gotten to the point and there
were going to go against what our core belief is.
I,
I don't fall on that.
I still,
it's crazy human ingenuity,
but it annoys me when people respond to like the Joe Rogan podcast saying like
these conservatives,
they,
they screamed small private business and small government up until they get
banned.
And I'm like,
I have always been in favor of regulating companies that are breaking rules.
I used to work for environmental organizations before the government regulating
Twitter right now at this point.
Absolutely.
I,
and this was only after the conversation with Jack because seeing the,
you know,
I respect you would be for the Trump government.
I mean,
which I assume you're not a big Trump guy.
You would know the government and definitely not for the government led by
Donald Trump to,
to regulate Twitter.
It's not just led by Trump.
I was audio Kazuyo Cortez and isn't how she got 3.5 million followers.
So she has influenced,
sure,
sure.
But there's an issue here.
If,
uh,
you know,
one of the things I said to them was,
if you are unwilling to uphold,
I,
I didn't say it as clearly as I've thought about,
I tweeted about it.
If you're unwilling to uphold the legal standard of public discourse set by the
rules of the Supreme Court in the Unite States constitution,
then you will face regulation and their unwillingness to do so and full,
full well knowing foreign governments are manipulating us to trick us into
voting for f.
Uh,
knowing that new knowledge was involved in this scheme,
to do Russian bots to cost the Republican's and election that that's terrifying
me.
Uh,
to me.
And I would rather see Twitter turned off right now switch gun if it meant we're
going to protect our democracy,
our democratic republic,
cause every gets mad at me.
Representative Republic through death,
through democratic institutions.
Do you think in a weird way that the Twitter people jack included want that?
That they actually,
yeah,
that they've realized and maybe that's why they're doing this little press thing
right now they've realized they can't control the beast anymore.
So what would be the best thing Jerry Solution?
Jerry.
Uh,
so what they do on periscope,
and Jack mentioned this is you'll get a notification,
is this comment.
Okay?
Yeah.
And I always say yes for the most part.
Like unless you said something like an incitement to violence or break the law,
I'm pretty much like,
yeah,
you got a stupid opinion,
but it's fine.
Twitter too to the same thing.
It absolves them of responsibility.
It clears the bias sample a hundred thousand random people in the,
in the country of the origin of tweet and then let them decide.
Yeah.
So when a vagina yesterday was saying [inaudible] let's,
they'll do it to the other way.
When these guys this morning called us Nazi's and fascists and whatever,
this usual nonsense that comes out and talking about the two of us,
um,
do you think that would be a violation of the rules that she laid out yesterday?
Verified accounts libeling people to get their people to attack you as a,
um,
not,
I mean he,
one of these guys called you and Nazi propagandists and I think he should be
allowed to.
I'm a fascist.
I'm for him being allowed to as well.
But I'm saying by the,
by the rules that she laid out yesterday,
do you think that should be allowed on their platform by,
by her rules,
not,
not your free speech rights?
Um,
the,
the problem is their rules are arbitrary.
I think,
uh,
we,
you know,
we saw a guy post a picture of Mike Cernovich in his underwear and uh,
the first time he did it,
he got a lock out.
Second time nothing happened.
Just my understanding.
So that's shocking to me.
I don't care where the photo came from.
Uh,
people are saying like,
oh,
it was on a public website.
I don't care.
You took a photo of somebody in a compromising position and posted it without
their permission.
Like that's crazy that Twitter allows that can't say,
I'm surprised they're harassment campaigns had been going on for years against
conservatives that Twitter does nothing about.
So am I surprised that this could be a violation of the rules if you do it to
someone else?
Of course Twitter would ban you if you were doing it to people.
Right.
You know,
you look at,
we've got,
we've got a problem.
Yeah.
Well exactly.
I mean you look at why when she read the first tweet from Sargon as to why he
got banned and he was saying,
he said a bunch of things like about white people and men.
These are not hate speech.
According to Twitter.
He wasn't saying a to anybody directly.
He was saying these phrases are not hate speech.
And Twitter said,
yes,
it is banned.
Well that's why our suspension,
so that's why people like us who were free speech.
People are so frustrated with this because it's like,
look,
you can clearly call a Jew in Nazi there.
It's no problem.
But if you called a black person the n word,
and obviously I'm not for doing that,
you'd be rooted in a second.
Anyone.
Yup.
Now you can argue whether you're be allowed to do that or not.
The subjective nature of it.
There's a slur for Jewish people that support supported the,
the Germans after the K and Tacos.
Well,
I don't want to say it.
Is that allowed?
Yeah,
I don't know.
The live stream probably just went down.
I've seen a bunch of people on the left using that calling people and I'm like,
dude,
that's a slur.
Like that's,
that's a,
that's an ethnic slur against Jewish people,
man.
Yeah.
How is that not being,
how did you know what,
here's my thing.
They know they have that extra layer of protection.
I mean,
write some,
something funny happened at the end of the stream we did where apparently it
didn't go down.
So Joe said,
we're done.
The mics were hot and now there's a conspiracy going around as to what I was
talking about.
Some people have incredibly pointed out truth,
like the,
what really happened and some people are getting conspiratorial after we ended
vagina asked me for the names of,
she said,
what was the Antifa tweet that did that,
that docs the cops?
And I said,
it's uh,
I gave you the link.
It's down now.
It was a bit.
Dot.
Ly Slash Antifa tweet,
I believe.
They took it down and she said,
and can you give me the names of the accounts that were threatening?
I said,
no,
I believe in minimizing harm.
It's an ethics and a part of the journey journalistic ethics where my,
my,
my primary concern is that after Lauren southern got taken down from Patrion a
lot of conservatives and were like pointing to,
it's going down saying,
why aren't they being taken down but a symmetrical,
I reached out to Jack Conti and said,
there's accusations of asymmetry based on these accounts and Jack immediate,
uh,
immediately band.
It's going down.
So now I said,
awe,
Whoa,
that was bad.
I did not want the tapping right from this point on,
I will never give a name of these companies so they can take action against
people who I'm at odds with.
That would be me using my weight for personal gain.
Once a stream ended,
she asked me for names.
I said,
no.
I began to explain when Lauren southern got taken out and then Joe's like
everybody out.
So two two,
two narratives emerged.
The first,
I can already see where the first was that p two and I,
this is,
this is what most people are sharing.
Tim Pool maintained his journalistic integrity.
Even we didn't know the Mites were alive and I'm like,
oh,
that's like,
that's sweet.
I see.
Like I'm like happy accident.
Some people are claiming that I'm refusing to share the names because they're
fake and I made it all up.
I'm like,
what ended up happening was after we left the room,
she asked me for the names and I was like,
which names specifically though?
Like what do you,
what do you ask?
She said,
I'm not going to ban them or anything.
I just want to know who was saying it to you.
And I was like,
I don't know what you're talking about.
Which specific particularly it's,
oh the people threatening you.
And I was like,
oh,
that was three,
three years,
three like two or three years ago.
I have,
it was just an antifa account.
Like I don't remember that.
It wasn't anybody high profile.
Is there a weird thing also where that getting people band or let's say the
people who are threatening you with violence or I've had people threaten me with
violence,
you know,
like some fairly serious things and that's the only time I really ever reported.
Every now and again someone writing really vile,
like,
like truly like really vile,
usually some gay reference and I'll report it just to see if Twitter does sang
about it cause I'm just trying to test the thing and they don't of course.
But the few times that I've gotten what I think are seemingly legit death
threats,
they have gotten rid of the accounts.
But then after they do it and you and I get the email back and it's like we've
suspended this account or terminate this county,
I'm always like,
did I just accomplish anything there?
Because if anything,
yeah.
Unless that person was then,
unless they used an IP address and I wouldn't be for any of this,
but unless they actually track down who this person was,
well now we've just enraged somebody who had a lot of rage beforehand.
Yeah.
So we probably just exacerbated the situation.
Block and mute.
That's fine.
I used to never block anybody.
Yeah.
I would just meet people who are incessant and bad faith actors.
But then I decided out of sight,
out of mind.
So although blocking someone doesn't prevent them from ever seeing your tweets,
it makes it much more,
much less likely that they'll see your tweet.
So I was like,
there's,
there's certain people I've blocked,
I think I've blocked maybe like 25 people,
bad faith actors who wait for our tweets.
Second plot of context,
like some of the people from yesterday with Joe Rogan,
the deck screenshots,
they lie about what was said,
but they know that their followers and have a fat,
well not,
we'll never fact check.
So then they just pushed that lie.
Uh,
I believe that people are allowed to be crazy and stupid.
So the people who are like the guy who was accusing me of being a far right
conspiracy theories and whenever I think he's lying,
I think he knows full well because that guy used to DM me and he was asking me
to like cover a certain issues up until I called him out for posting the
threatening to post revenge porn if Cernovich now he's angry and I was lying.
He said about,
maybe I'll make this clear.
Yeah,
so people are probably gonna pick,
they probably know who this guy is because there's a meme going around.
If me saying journalists are going to do this,
then he does this.
Just to be clear,
this guy was asking me to cover stories for him up until he got mad at me and
now he's claiming on far right.
This is asking me for help.
Does that mean that he regularly dams far right conspiracy theorists that he
think are acting in bad faith for help?
Well this is the problem and those are the other guy who was like,
I used to be two pools roommate,
straight up lie.
He posted a straight up lie and I'm like,
you want me to post the dms?
I can prove you're lying.
So is there nuts?
So let's take this to a different metal level for a second.
How to Twitter for just a moment,
but do you think this the basic,
the basic quest for truth,
let's say that some people are on versus just the rest of this crew that wants
to just watch scorched earth or just destroy everything that that really is what
the culture wars about.
Cause you and I have pretty significant political differences and it is cool.
And I know,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
it's,
it's irrelevant to me.
I think it's irrelevant to you.
You know,
we can,
we can do those discussions and we've done them before.
Yeah.
I don't think we would do them now because there's so many other things to talk
about.
But it's like,
I think we both know that we're on basically the same quest for something that's
true,
so decent that we want people to live free.
But,
but that's what the culture war really is about.
It's that you've got this little sliver of people trying really trying and we're
dealing with people that basically act like,
like Heath Ledger's joker I think.
I think it to burn,
but I think there's a sociopath's left and the right's got him.
There are people that I believe on the left and the right who are grifters,
I don't know which side has more or less.
Um,
I don't publicly call out people as grifters because I can never prove even to
myself.
I'm like,
I think something about that person.
I don't trust them.
But that would,
that would be really unfair to accuse them of being disingenuous on things that
they're truly passionate about.
But I think what we have kind of in the culture war is,
you know,
I saw something on Twitter where there's this activist who works for NBC and
he's literally activist.
He's lobbied Twitter for action.
So I can't call him a journalist.
And he was claiming that everyone who criticized captain marvel or Brie Larson
was an insult.
I said,
I did a piece on it today and I'm like,
you can't,
you can't clearly think that every single person is not getting late.
It's a really,
you're very clearly trying to trigger an attack people.
But the important point was that for the record,
I'm getting laid and I have no desire to see it.
Well,
yeah,
but so the point,
you know,
I tried to bring up just calmly to one,
uh,
it was a buzzword reporter who quoted it.
I didn't argue for or against.
I said,
here's what people are thinking.
And his response was that I was engaged in far right propaganda and I've lost my
mind.
And I'm like,
he was like,
I don't see any of these conversations on reddit.
Therefore it's far right propaganda.
Youtube is dominated by far right propaganda.
And I'm like,
I realized something because someone commented this,
reddit is moderated,
particularly by the companies,
you know,
they want to make sure they're promoting their content.
And there's very few things that can appear.
But Youtube is a very libertarian platform where whatever works works,
it's a very meritocratic.
So on youtube for video is good.
And entertaining people watch it.
What does that mean?
Well,
they're not in cells.
It means that a lot of people are watching these videos and youtube is saying,
if people like it,
we're going to show it.
That's not a rabbit hole of conspiracy theories.
It's a lot of these videos.
Uh,
Chris doesn't captain marvel very simply.
People saying,
I'm sure the movie will do well.
I'm sure it's going to be like a moderately good marvel film.
I just don't like Brie Larson because she's very snooty and condescending.
I'm going to sit this one out.
There are some people who are completely how I feel.
Right.
Level of the marvel movies,
right.
Boom event.
Infinity War was I think the best one.
That would great.
Yeah.
I'm so excited for the best one.
I can't wait for the next one and I have no desire to see it cause I saw her
little speech and it's like,
you know what?
I just don't want to support you.
We,
if we keep supporting these people who are so contrary to the,
at least the things that I believe in,
it's like the only way you're going to ever get change because I don't want the
government to stop them.
I want,
I want them to stop themselves.
But so,
so here's the thing,
I don't,
I don't feel that way for me.
It's kind of that,
uh,
they marketed,
the movie has a big feminist film,
Brie Larson zone words.
The commercial has a big her in the screen and then a and o appears.
So it says a hero.
And I'm like,
I see where they're going with this.
I sat there,
Ghostbusters,
I sat to the last Shaddai.
I'm going to sit this one out until the reviews come in.
I got no beef with marvel or Brie Larson.
I don't like the things she says.
But Chris Evans,
Captain America says crazy things too.
Well,
mark,
rough alone makes him right.
Right,
right.
So I can separate the art from the artist.
But when your marketing is overwhelmingly reminiscent of Ghostbusters and last
Jedi,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna wait and I'm hearing it's boring.
You know,
it's got like a 6.6 on Metacritic and even left wing outlets are saying it's
mediocre and boring at best.
So I'm like,
maybe I won't see it.
You know,
definitely was the Nazi trolls that have screwed.
Oh,
and that's the craziest thing are the ratings.
They're already,
they're already seeing that there's a,
an outlet that wrote a story saying,
Oh,
trolls are uh,
right,
right wing trolls or preparing a campaign to destroy the ratings.
And they're,
they're a story was we saw one person on Twitter who said,
let's do this.
And I was like,
how many he had,
he had apparently had no followers.
I'm like,
random Twitter.
How did you make it?
Like who cares what?
But that's why this is also is so strange to me because we can see these trends
all over the place.
So we'll remember when there was that video of Kazuo Cortez dancing.
Nobody cared.
Nobody cared complimented her.
I saw all the conservatives,
well all of them,
all the verified conservatives that have any following of note where like,
oh,
this is kind of cute,
or I don't like her,
but she's a human,
Blah Blah.
And then,
but all the,
all the,
uh,
the mainstream conservatives going crazy and most of them,
they didn't link to anything where they would link to an anonymous account that
you don't even know.
It was one account that sounded like that.
Was that Newsweek?
Which one?
It was.
It was anonymous.
Uh,
no.
I know,
but what,
what,
uh,
outlet row.
Oh,
that article.
I don't know.
But they were,
I was everyone your times wrote about it.
Yeah.
When I first saw that video,
I laughed and I said,
I tweeted something like,
wow,
this makes her seem really relatable and endearing.
It's really,
it's a,
I said,
it makes her look like she's fun and I come like,
I was like a compliment.
I'm like,
wow,
that's really cool that we have this video of like a college fun time.
They were recreating breakfast club dances.
I mean,
I don't,
I know that those people will look me in with conservatives.
I don't think of me that way.
But the first response I saw from ever,
literally everybody was like,
lol,
this is so funny.
Like it's fun,
Ha.
But then when you see that at the political level and we see it all the time,
it's sort of the game or level or the Twitter level or whatever.
You realize that these,
these themes,
like it doesn't take a genius to put some of this together,
but all right,
let's,
let's shift a little bit.
So first off we're going to do,
we'll do like an hour of Q and a from the audience.
Yeah.
You down for that,
whatever,
whatever.
We're going to do that.
But I want,
I want to do a bunch of work here at first,
but people can submit on,
on the super chat right now.
Let's talk about,
uh,
my favorite organization in America even more.
I like these guys even more than the southern poverty hates enter data and
society.
Oh,
that conspiracy theater transition a bit about data and society.
They put up a chart.
The alternative influence or now they're directly associated when they put
their,
they're directly connected to the daily stormer.
Yeah,
it's a fact,
and I,
I've mentioned this in the past and people on the left had the same reaction
that we have to their conspiracy theory,
crime web and actually the connection between data and society to Neo Nazis is
extremely direct relative to what they claimed.
So one of their advisors has appeared years just what data society.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
in society is a,
it's a New York based think tank of progressives that are tracking data,
social media and how it impacts society.
And they do a lot of research looking into far right and Russian interference.
One of the people,
uh,
so I,
this is great and I hope,
I hope they're listening.
I have an insider who's been feeding me information and I know they're working
on like a Russian document right now.
And the woman who was writing it tweets every three minutes about some
nonsensical conspiracy theory.
And I laughed.
I'm like,
it represents them very well,
but I hope they're listening and they know that I've,
yeah,
somebody inside their organization has sent me like,
so I also know that they've admitted the connections in their report.
The alternative influence network,
they're a direct quote sent to me was some of these are not factual.
So I have,
you know,
and that's,
and that's how I admitted to you that the report was doable.
I don't want to say related to mean basically just about your names.
I'll,
I'll say this.
I have been fed insider information and one of the statements given to me by an
individual,
not from them,
but through someone associated in a certain capacity.
I'm very,
I'm trying to be very careful not to expose,
uh,
was a quote.
Some of these are not factual and there's more there.
Um,
but that was,
that was,
you know,
yeah.
So I'll ultimately,
I've just,
you know,
whatever.
Right.
But what's interesting about it is it's not just whatever,
because we then see how these studies that were based in nothing other than,
Oh,
this person appeared with this person,
or this person did a live stream with this person.
And then you link it together and it looks like some sort of massive network.
Okay.
He's ridiculous scheming together and the connections are fake.
Some of them are connections were often fake,
but not only that,
there was no evidence that the whole premise of it,
this alternative influence network was that this group of people that included
Sam Harris and Jordan Peterson and you and me and a whole bunch of others that
we've radicalized people to the far right when in fact there is actual data.
Right.
The objective as has shown that I've actually read dean radicalized people have
the right and made them more liberal in a lot of cases.
And I've actually not that anecdote evidence is,
is enough ended up well,
but I have a lot of evidence more,
but more importantly,
it claims that youtube channels.
Okay.
Sam Harris,
does he have a youtube channel?
I'm pretty sure he does.
Um,
but they also mentioned James Demore who at the,
at least at the time,
there was four people listed that weren't youtube burrs,
some that were on youtube with like a thousand subscribers.
I posted one or two videos at some point and I'm like,
that's a fake,
it's fake narrative.
But,
but let's,
I want to make something absolutely clear that thing that I had muted on Twitter
because I can,
cause we're,
they're going after me and the,
the,
the report is implying that we're like,
oh yeah.
And,
and,
and they tried to get into,
they,
they try to dance around the nuance of understanding that,
uh,
one of the problems was they said these people hold views from libertarian to
see mainstream conservative libertarian to white nationalists.
I don't fit that bracket at all.
Absolutely not.
Uh,
simply because I defend,
you're not a white nationalist.
Oh yeah.
My,
my,
my mixed race family would fit really,
really well into a white notes are completely,
oh,
it's half Korean quarter Korean actually quoted.
Yeah,
I've half white.
So,
so,
so here's the important thing.
One of the advisers to data and society has appeared on numerous podcasts and
praised,
uh,
the former web dev from the daily stormer.
She was heavily criticized for this has tried coming out and making like,
you know,
oh no,
no,
it's just my research.
But there's a podcast from a,
I believe it may be from w NYC where she's talking about,
no,
this neo Nazi guy,
it's all just jokes.
It's all just lol,
lol,
the big swastika on his chest and all these things.
It's just funny.
Ha Ha.
And that's,
that's one of their advisors.
So if they want,
if they want to lay accusations towards me,
because I w I kid you not,
one of their accusations was that in a video,
someone walked past me.
I was at a party at vidcon where there's thousands of people I've never met.
I showed up to do an interview with a guy and as,
as someone's interviewing and talking to me on their camera,
someone was like walked in after the fact and she says that connects them.
It's like,
okay,
I never had a word to that person.
I've never met them.
I just saw them at a party.
When you and shake hands,
your organization has an advisor who has appeared on shows and praised an actual
neo Nazi.
Well,
depending on who you ask will say he's not really a neo Nazi.
I don't want to drag people by naming them,
but it's an individual who is one of the most notorious trolls on the planet,
was associated with daily stormer,
has a swastika on their chest.
I'll leave it there and I will point out to people who know the woman and this
man will say it's unfair to characterize them in that manner.
But if we're going by the standards set by data and society there,
you literally have a woman who's written a book and defended too to the extent
which that it's just a joke.
It's just a game.
It's,
it's,
it's funny.
Well tell that to them they should tell it to themselves if they think it's
funny cause you get a tattoo of a swastika on your chest and to to make
horrifying jokes about marginalized communities.
That's their standard for what's funny or at least one of their advisors.
I have to question their motives when they want to accuse me of being a gateway
to anything.
Maybe we should look internally,
you know,
clean your house,
clean your room before trying to change the world.
Right.
It's right over there.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
what do you make of the fact the way that,
okay,
so these,
these reports come out and then immediately huffpo daily beast.
Everybody jumps on board them.
Vox did a big piece on it as reclined even tagged me in the tweet to voting the
article to me.
Oh yeah.
Um,
that they all didn't,
they use it as,
oh,
we've got evidence of it and what I see evidence of that these,
these are the outright radicalists and that,
you know,
you're making turning people into white nationalists and I'm turning people into
homophobes or some,
some ridiculous nonsense.
But what I think is most fascinating about it is it's like if you look at the
people in that group,
most of them are sort of self funded or Patrion or youtube or some of them
probably have other jobs.
You know,
vox is funded by like hundreds of millions of dollars of VC money and they feel
the need to go after Chris Ragan who is a freaking like I like I like a lot,
but he's a Bernie Bro video game.
So it shows you that the power really has shifted where they know it's like
their lives and their Lou your rally losing.
You know what I mean?
What annoyed me about the Ezra Klein thing?
He said this really is the right
actionary right.
And I'm like,
I made a documentary in hour long documentary about institutional racism.
Uh,
I have only ever defended,
um,
social justice policy in terms of the problems of institutional racism,
the importance of protecting marginalized communities.
My issue is that I'm on the libertarian spectrum towards the left.
These are people who are hippie pot-smoking sit on the beach with dreads and
chill.
There's are the people that I,
with skateboarders,
we want to be left alone,
but we're all friends and we want to have hugs and we want to have vegan food.
People have,
oh no,
my whole life.
So we're,
we're the kind of people who are like,
Nah man,
like we should,
we should do the best to cooperate and end these oppressive things.
But you silencing other people,
you accusing other people smearing them,
attacking them and being racist are things I don't agree with.
Linda Sarsour was just dragging Nancy Polosi for being a white feminist who
supports white patriarchy and I'm like,
yes,
I agree that we should respect all peoples of different faiths and national,
a national origins,
gender identity,
etc. You are not doing that.
You're literally trying to weaponize the color of this woman's skin if there's a
racist in the equation.
If Linda start somewhere.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So how is it that that makes me reactionary,
right.
When I'm actually in favor of upholding the tenants of social justice without
being an authoritarian mean person,
I'm gonna avoid swearing,
you know?
Yeah.
Let's do the political thing quick.
Are you forgetting marriage at well,
yeah,
of course.
The two.
Okay.
That's pretty lucky.
You are for abortion.
You're pro choice.
I'm pro choice.
I'm pro choice to,
okay.
That seems pretty lefty or there's nuance there too.
Are you guys death penalty?
Absolutely.
Against him.
Against the death penalty to,
are you hungry?
Strong public education?
Yeah.
100%.
Me Too.
Are you a for euthanasia?
Uh,
they give you a death.
we know that you have a right to decide at the end of your,
oh yeah,
that's a pretty lefty thing.
Um,
what,
right,
right.
And,
and,
um,
a right to try.
What does that,
the experimental medications.
Yeah.
I'll go one step further than you,
that's more of a libertarian thing.
I'm for progressive tax.
Uh,
I'm in favor of minimum wage.
Both of these students come with caveats.
Uh,
I believe clearly against both of those.
I believe on the left the rug now if you will.
And I believe that we should do student loan forgiveness.
I believe that there's a bunch of other areas where there's a discussion there.
Yup.
Yup,
Uh,
so I,
I can go on,
but it's like,
uh,
this is it.
It's crazy.
When I say I supported Bernie and people like he's lying and I'm like,
watch my videos.
I'll point out the insanity of the green new deal.
Try.
The second page of the green new deal is like racial equity.
Equity is not equality.
Why is my environmental bill being plagued by identitarianism?
That makes me angry.
I like environmental as I'm,
I'm in favor of environmental regulation.
Yeah.
And,
and I'm an,
I've been,
I have been on this,
in this business is all of my life.
It's almost like no matter what Democrats,
it's crazy to me.
And the funny thing is I made a video about Linda Sarsour dragging Nancy Polosi
today and I thought it was funny how like,
I've actually probably complimented Nancy Pelosi even though I don't like the
corporatist mainstream Democrats because I thought about an unlike,
well,
my only real gripe with her is how she handles her business with Trump.
Not really her position.
She mocked the green new deal.
And I,
I agree with her.
So there's a lot of mainstream Democrats that,
you know,
I don't care from mainstream,
moderate Republicans,
Democrats,
I don't care about that.
My concern is cultural politics,
ground level protest.
What do I see?
Do we have far right white nationalists and on the Republican side of Congress,
while there are some people you can live with,
accusations against Steve King got removed from what?
Of Committees.
But what else do you have?
Um,
not,
not too much,
but the left is going to claim Trump is,
he hasn't.
Then you're going to have on the left you have Kirsten Gillibrand the future.
The future is female intersectional.
Oh,
that's identitarianism.
I don't like that you have Alexandria Kazuo Cortez Green new deal.
Identitarianism you have Elon.
I'm did sleep there all identitarian so I look at the left and I'm like,
all of these people want to enact policy based on the color of someone's skin.
I've experienced that my life from the left and the right.
And I do not want to live in that world where I've had a white people,
you know,
a white supremacists vandalized my,
my,
my family's home when I was little.
My mom has explained to us that this is part of the world.
People who don't like mixed race families.
I,
I've to occupy Wall Street.
My God do.
I did.
I get to experience the beauty of being not white or,
or a person of color because you're mixed and they,
the,
the people on the left say,
you're too white.
You don't get to speak,
but I'm mixed.
Too Bad.
Then you have other people saying,
I only will listen to you because you're mixing.
I'm like,
well,
which one is which?
Who Do I,
I hate it.
I hate all of it.
I don't want it.
What do you think if we were really doing like the Psych One oh one on this
condition,
because I actually am starting to think it's sort of like a mental condition.
It's a mass mental condition that's going on because it's not based.
In fact,
so no matter how much you explain to these people that you're for the individual
and you want everyone to live free and you're not a big hit,
and the opposite of fashion and all of these things in the opposite of their
closer to fascists than we would ever be.
Well,
the guy,
the verified guy who was calling me a fascist today,
also tagged stitcher radio in the tweet because they're,
they're my hosting service now.
They don't host my podcast.
Anyway,
we're were released on Stitcher,
on them,
many of them.
But I go,
who is acting as a fascist here?
Me,
the Guy Defending Andrew individual rights and freedom.
Or The guy who's attacking me,
calling me a fascist and trying to get me booted off the plane.
This is one of those has more fascism in it than the,
I think at a,
at a certain level that it was partly an accident,
but partly on purpose that this,
this culture came to exist.
People who are racist realized people hate racism.
What do you do?
Claim to fight racism and empower racists.
So what are we seeing antifascists been Portland screaming,
racial slurs,
a police screaming racial slurs at,
at,
at the,
those,
you know,
criticize Patriot prayer all you want,
they've said as hadn't done really awful things.
Um,
in terms of their,
there've been videos of a tiny punching,
someone starting a fight.
I've seen it all,
but at the same time,
you point out the people who run Patriot repair or not white.
So when white people show up,
white progressive's claiming their anti racists screaming racial slurs at police
screaming racial slurs that conservatives bio means have your disagreements with
that group.
But I'm pretty sure you're the racists like that.
Even by your own standard.
That's what I mean about a mass mental condition.
Because you know,
Bret Weinstein,
when the whole thing was happening at evergreen state,
he kept saying,
I thought this was the most fascinating part of the whole thing.
Beyond the absurdity of know being called racist for not wanting the school to
be segregated.
Sort of easy putting that aside.
Um,
he said that the students that he actually feared,
we're not the minority students.
It was the white students behind them who had that look of,
you know,
we've got the bat and we're going to Google you.
They're white.
They have to really prove it right.
They have to really prove it.
They're a form of white supremacists and this,
so I kind of,
I was planning this way for years.
You have the what's called like a right wing white supremacist.
These are people who believe that white people should be supreme and that they,
they,
they try to accomplish that.
And do you think these people have any incident of what you already said?
No.
I mean look there,
there are absolutely some people in power who hold these views.
I think it would be absurd not to think so,
but I don't think I thought,
I don't think it's as widespread as the left tries to claim it as any degree and
taught at universities.
I was working now is it?
Yeah,
but here's the thing.
The left left,
left wing and right wing,
left wing white supremacy is the idea that why people are supreme and so you end
up with over with,
with white people believing they're the white saviors that must force other
white people to do as they're told.
And so it gets really weird then when these left wing individuals who believe
that white people are supreme tell minorities what to do.
White supremacists,
you know,
I've told this story a couple of times.
We'll do a couple more minutes here and then we're going to do a Q and a.
So get your questions in on super chat right now.
Um,
but one of my real wake up moments to all of this,
I was on TYT once and you know,
they were playing the clip of Fox News and do you might know David Webb who's a
conservative who happens to be black and we were falling.
That's right.
We were friends from our old Sirius XM days.
We used to go out to dinner and have drinks and whatever.
And one of the hosts,
a white progressive who didn't know David Ignore,
know,
knew that I knew him,
kept saying that he's the token black guy.
He's,
and it's like,
yeah,
he's the uncle Tom.
He's like whatever you want to call it.
And that was one of the first moments for me where it was so obvious what it
was.
Cause I know David and I know he believes what he's believed.
David's the one that he was on with,
uh,
Arriva Martin who's a progressive also.
And she didn't even realize,
I was like,
oh yeah.
And she called him out for his white privilege.
And then he goes,
yeah.
He goes,
well,
I'm black.
And then she goes,
my people gave me the wrong information as if,
as if it's true.
Like,
Oh,
who are you speaking to?
Was a white guy or black guy during occupy Wall Street.
There was an argument about the merit of work or something.
I said a few things and was told as a white person,
I didn't understand and my opinions were invalid because I could never
understand being a marginalized person.
And then I said,
I'm actually mixed race.
And the response was,
oh,
I see what you're saying now.
No,
no,
I get it now.
And,
and I laughed.
I'm like,
you're racist.
Like you'll only listen to me because you think I'm not white.
Like you're a racist when you,
it's the soft bigotry of low expectations.
We also,
it's like,
would you ever want that?
Like how big God damn deal.
I would never want anyone to give me anything better than the quality which you
don't give me.
So,
so amber Tamblyn,
uh,
there's a story that was out today or yesterday about a amber Tamblyn saying
she's not going to vote for Bernie.
She wants support a woman.
And she said something like,
we now have a choice.
And to me,
I thought that was crazy.
I'm like,
as much as I am excited for the,
you know,
people of color and women who are running for office,
I certainly think that their perspectives,
we'll bring a unique,
you know,
value to our political climate.
I wouldn't base my,
my vote on the color of their skin or their gender,
but here is someone who actually says,
Bernie,
you're great but woman.
And I'm like,
that doesn't mean your ideas are good.
Yeah.
There's a certain perspective you might hold that might be valuable.
If that's expressed,
I would vote for the expressed perspective,
but I'm not going to be like,
I won't vote for a man.
Are we going to do what do what a female Hitler emergence?
Or you're going to be like,
well,
it's a woman or you're going to vote for,
uh,
we talked like,
it's crazy though.
I hate to tell you this as a Bernie guy,
but they're coming in for Birdie.
I mean,
well at the end of the day,
by the next year and a half of an election,
Bernie is the old white guy at the end.
That's what you'd be already is and he will be done in destroyed by it is
increasing and this is why and that that was the whole thing.
In a weird way,
in 2015 this is an important story.
I was walking with one of my coworkers at fusion frothing at the mouth about how
much I loved Bernie.
I was ranting loudly like going through all the things he said and done.
Here's the important thing people don't realize.
In 2015 Bernie Sanders says no open borders.
That's a Koch brothers proposal.
He says he's free trade agreements destroyed manufacturing this country,
we need stronger borders.
Illegal immigration is bad because it's hurting the middle class and the and the
lower class and I'm like,
he also talked about student loan forgiveness,
expanding programs.
He's a little too left for me and a lot of areas,
but I was like,
this is a guy who means it.
It's one of the first times,
but more importantly,
out of out of everything he was saying,
gun issue.
It's an urban versus rural debate.
I'm like,
wow,
that's true.
There's a very dramatic difference in perspective here.
I was like,
this guy's telling the truth.
What happens once it gets on stage?
White people don't know what it's like to be poor.
Whoa,
Bernie.
That was pretty good.
That's all.
I wasn't even trying.
I'm like,
that.
That's not true.
What's going on here?
Then he goes,
we must get equal pay for women,
and I'm like,
we have three law is in place already.
Bernie,
what are you doing now?
I'm looking at the future we're in and I'm like,
Bernie decided to endorse Hillary and he and he started pushing this narrative
that has stepped him.
He's,
it's backfired on him.
Now they're saying,
I won't vote for a white men.
Sorry,
Bernie by,
there you go.
That's what you got.
So I've met with three houses though.
I will say this though,
I would,
I,
I still lean in his direction.
Um,
I I do think is a little further to the left than I am,
but I,
even after all of these things,
if I was going to vote and I'm,
I probably won't because I don't trust anybody.
If I would vote,
he still has some Brownie points from me.
I still,
I still do like him,
but I think he's kind of,
he shouldn't endorse Hillary.
He shouldn't have pushed it into Terry and stuff.
And that really,
really pushed me away from him.
It did.
So,
uh,
I'm,
I'm taking a close look at Tulsi Gabbert right now and I don't know if there's
anyone else I'd actually be interested in and I don't know a lot about Tulsa,
so I don't want to say like I definitely would vote for,
but there's,
there's a lot of things I like about her in terms of anti imperialism,
no intervention in foreign wars and things like that.
That sounds very trumpy into well but,
but it's,
it's libertarian,
right?
So you can be a right,
a right libertarian,
left libertarian.
The,
the difference is what really bothers me is people always show the political
compass and they say Antifa is left libertarian.
Then as not true,
Antifa uses violence to force an ideology on other people.
Left Libertarian are people with dreadlocks and peace symbols.
They're sitting on a beach going or whatever and they want to be left alone,
but they're cooperative,
so anarcho communism,
it exists.
It's simple.
It's 10 people who live on a farm and one person grows corn.
One person,
you know cooks meat and they just share and there's no real debate about who's
doing more than the other.
There's no quantification of the value.
I'll go.
Communism works really,
really well in small groups.
It works really,
really bad when you have to connect different communities to each other and
quantify the amount of labor versus the value being given,
in which case currency becomes extremely important and communism doesn't work at
large scales without killing millions of people and getting into it.
So you may not be the perfect solution for absolutely.
It's absolutely monopolist system of 350 something and then people with
different thoughts.
And the annoying thing to me is a,
I believe in a mixed economy,
um,
you have to have aspects of a free market.
You have to have some environment,
you have to some regulatory controls.
I believe social programs are important because,
uh,
the laissez faire capitalism in my opinion,
results in runaway corporations and then it's no flex in an avalanche,
right?
So I often use the,
uh,
clean water restoration act as an example.
This,
the crane,
the clean water restoration act came out and I could begin my data wrong.
It's been 15 years since I worked for these environmental organizations after a
river in Ohio started on fire because a bunch of different car companies were
dumping pollution.
But at times it's not,
not very large levels.
So individually they'll look,
look,
I'm not doing anything.
We're pretty,
it's a,
it's a minor amount.
You needed someone to look at the bigger picture and be like,
guys,
it's on fire.
And it's because all of you together make a big problem.
So,
uh,
a social contract was formed and everyone agreed to it and there's someone to
enforce it.
So,
um,
I believe,
you know,
that's where I get with regulation,
but that's why I believe unchecked capitalism results in unfortunate veering off
in random directions,
which can cause problems,
right?
Yeah.
All right,
so that,
so let's just,
let's just do a little bit of youtube before we go too far,
politics wise,
right.
There's a little more on youtube though.
And then we'll do the Q and a.
So what do you make of what's going on on Youtube?
Because I get people every day nine,
I'm not talking about the trolls and the reddit losers and all that.
I'm talking about real people who I know.
I mean it's often people that I've met at events who email me and say,
Dave,
I've got unsubscribed from channel.
I call out youtube on it all the time.
Once years ago I had an email address of someone at Youtube.
They actually gave me an email address and someone at Youtube told me there was
a bug on my channel.
Then when I followed up,
they stopped responding.
And then why don't you leave?
They told me to not.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
And didn't you have like a livestream locked in place?
Was that you?
Oh yeah.
We had to leave alive.
So if you would go to my homepage,
you know,
youtube.com/rubin report,
the video on the front would always say,
uh,
the Rubin report is now alive even though we weren't.
So people would just,
well click away.
And the point is,
without getting into all the bugs are just cry me a river.
All of this shit,
all of this shit that we all kind of know.
Unsubscribes videos.
No,
not going to feeds the demonetization.
They demonetize my video with Peter Boghossian and James Lindsey about,
but it's really complicated.
Yeah.
So I'm just,
I'm just,
I'm just shoveling stuff out here.
I made it.
I made a video,
uh,
John Stewart praise the Trump administration over the handling of the nine 11
victims fund made a video.
And I said,
uh,
John Stewart praises Trump over nine 11 victims fund.
And the point of that video was,
I agree with John Stewart wholeheartedly cut the politics out.
These are people who sacrificed their lives to to save lives.
And I,
I fully agree with doing everything we have to to take care of our first
responders,
the video doing well,
but listed no views until I took nine 11 out and changed it with first
responders.
All of a sudden the views reappeared.
I made another video about a woman,
a Muslim woman from Egypt who was being berated by another woman in a parking
lot.
And the point I was making with that video is I typically don't make videos
about this because these people are being shamed already.
It's like,
of course I don't agree with running up to a Muslim person and screaming at him.
And so this poor woman,
I am holy in her defense.
And that was throttled to an extreme degree probably because it was about,
you know,
Islam or Muslim or something.
And so first I'll say Hanlon's razor never attribute to malice,
which is,
he's explained by incompetence.
The do you monetization thing is rent is seemingly random.
So my,
my mom makes math videos,
they get demonetized nothing in them.
It's like two plus two is four and it's you monetized,
I mean I made a video where I went to a raccoon cafe in Japan with my buddy
Luke,
and we're literally just feeding raccoons and giggling while hockey family music
place.
Cause I thought it'd be a fun video to make.
Do you monetized?
So,
so I get that a lot of it could be random and it could be just,
you know,
just ineptitude and all that.
The one that I just mentioned though,
where it already had a couple of hundred thousand views with Peter and you know,
when we're talking about the circle hooks and all that,
it's all about academia.
I mean,
this is not something that could have an ad on it.
Uh,
it got through the algorithm and it was monetized at first and then it was
manually confirm a manual review,
confirmed review unmonitored.
Then I had to fight it publicly and they monetize it again.
Wow.
That's,
yeah.
So that,
but,
but that's the finding that time is evidenced,
that's what I'm saying.
The reason I'm,
the reason I always do this is because this is the only course of,
I don't like doing it,
but it's the only course of action we have.
And this is then where I think some of the lefties we'd say,
and now some of the Trump people would say government regulation,
they own all the pipes,
they own all the information.
And so I'll say this,
um,
I said earlier,
I would welcome regulation against Twitter because I believe it's becoming so
detrimental,
especially after talking to Jack and,
uh,
um,
a vagina that that really tells you how the conversation went.
Well,
they,
they look me in the eyes and said,
we are going to do what we think is right.
We are an unelected.
Listen,
Twitter is an unelected council of the Uber elite millionaires who are dictating
what people can or can't say on one of the most important public platforms in
our country,
in the world.
Who,
who,
who determined they should have that influence over our elections.
I don't like a citizens United.
And yes,
I understand the nuances with,
you know,
taking away the right to speech through money means that best media companies
will hold so much power.
It's complicated.
I don't want billionaires dictating our elections.
I don't want oligopolies forming and I certainly don't want Twitter joining
their party.
I see them say this and I say,
you know what?
Maybe the best thing would be a sledgehammer right now because the debate is,
is basically over.
They said,
they said basically we allow speech on our platform.
If you follow our rules while we know people are getting elected through your,
through your platform,
and you've excised a large portion of the population,
knock it down,
here's a problem.
Regulation wouldn't actually work on youtube or on other platforms because you
can't regulate to,
to create technology.
The government can't go to youtube and say,
you must invent something.
Something just happened recently in Canada.
Well,
no,
but they could say you,
you have to treat all traffic equally.
You have to get,
sure it's impossible.
No,
I'm not saying they should.
Wait,
what do you mean?
What do you mean?
So,
uh,
youtube absolutely impossible.
Twitter.
It's more possible because Twitter could just timeline out,
like everything is chronological,
were done.
A bandings will based on First Amendment Youtube.
When you go to youtube.com there's 15 videos they show you that you can see
there's 10 and then there's another bracket below,
which usually is like a single person's channel.
They have to have an algorithm to determine what they should feed you.
Otherwise no one gets any content fed to them at all.
Right.
So I get it.
It's not in a purely chronological feed that it doesn't work that way.
But there could,
again,
I see I'm not for this,
so it's hard to,
it's hard to take this position,
but if the government came in,
there was something they could say that would probably make it fairer.
I would not be for this.
So.
So you,
so with the monetization you have no right to an advertiser,
youtube is acting as your agent to sell chance.
Absolutely.
And even when you demonetize,
you still get a little bit when it comes to promotion,
the Youtube Algorithm right now is probably one of the best meritocratic systems
for content.
If your content is good.
Like I've had,
I've had unprecedented growth like in my career with youtube.
It took me years.
I've been doing this for,
you know,
what,
eight years now.
And,
and uh,
I gained,
I hit 100,000 subs in like three months of actively being on Youtube.
It took me six years to get that on Twitter because Twitter is about,
is people going to have people going to share your content?
Well,
what works on Twitter is rage,
anger,
calling someone a Nazi.
You'll get retweets that gets you followers on Youtube.
It's making compelling content.
So you took the way better.
In my opinion,
the government will not be able to regulate youtube into working better.
They won't.
So regulation won't work for Twitter.
I'm sorry,
what worked for Youtube?
It will work for Twitter and Facebook.
Uh,
Youtube could regulate,
uh,
couldn't be regulated in certain capacities like a monkey.
Jones deserves every shout out.
I get possible whenever I do a video.
His channel was deleted without breaking any rules.
He made really edgy content.
He made fun of Elliot Roger.
That's that shooter,
that incell shooter.
And it was very clearly mocking the sky,
but for whatever reason youtube said terminated his channel.
And I,
I still,
I still think it's important point out youtube does better than most other
platforms in terms of protecting the rights of,
of speech.
I really do believe that because I'll give you an example.
Sargon said a naughty word on youtube.
It's still there.
It's still there,
patriot and banned him.
So youtube was like,
this video is not stripped of any rights or anything.
We understand the context and so I can respect you to still pointing out
monkeys.
Band was insane.
It terrifying and really scary.
I'm,
I'm with you that I would chalk a lot of this up to just general ineptitude or
just that the thing has become so big.
You know,
it's a Goliath now and well,
you know,
maybe you can't,
it can't withstand its own thing and the political forces and everything else.
Um,
but I'm still,
I'm still not for regulators and hear them,
but it's an interesting,
you can't ride around into discussion with many people and it's an interest five
to have.
Youtube is also really important for,
uh,
elections.
But the system,
the algorithm is it's meritocratic.
Meaning well,
what if you knew tomorrow that within the algorithm they were doing something to
limit the scope of your videos,
the ability for your own subscribers.
I have to get your videos so you have three channels or they were making sure
that your people were being unsubscribed or a series of other things that there
is often much evidence to believe is happening.
What we got and then what do you do?
Hedge your bets.
I,
this is why I started a second channel and now I'm launching subverse.
I recognize that uh,
trying to make a living just off of youtube alone.
What isn't,
isn't isn't a safe bet because I've seen in the past it's not just us that's
been affected by this.
There are people who just not even for political reasons,
youtube,
we'll say we need to change the algorithm for x reason and then all of a sudden
someone's traffic drops by 80% so I recognize there's politics behind a lot of
it.
I trust that youtube for the most part is trying its best.
But I do think that they're going to take a utilitarian approach in that Monkey
Jones deleted channel even though to break any rules cause he's a threat to us.
That's,
that's Bs and that that worries me a lot.
Uh,
but,
but ultimately I think the only thing you can really do is make alternate
channels and keep trying to figure out and evolve.
You can't just,
you can't just cross your fingers and hope Youtube.
Cause here's the thing.
Look,
youtube.com has 15 videos and that's the majority of most people's content.
When someone goes to youtube.com your videos there,
youtube has no obligation to promote you when they do that.
And there's no guarantee your content will,
will always fit what the algorithm wants.
So you,
you make content,
you're,
you know,
your,
your skyrocketing,
I think,
are you over a million yet?
You're really close to a million.
We were right under it,
but I probably would have been there a year ago.
But yeah,
so you're doing really well.
Everything's working.
But because your content is the same,
youtube changes the algorithm like trace at several times a day,
one day your traffic might just vanish and it's not political and you won't know
why.
Right?
So it's that.
It's the sort of lack of transparency and maybe there's interesting arguments
why there has to be a three.
Because when they,
when they were more open with it,
it was all gamed and the videos were awful.
Like I remember back in the day it,
there'll be a video called like it,
you know,
something stupid like big beautiful men bouncing on beach balls and you click
it,
it's a black screen because they just want you to click it.
Well,
I mean I started this show on to Uit and that's what they taught us how to do
all of the worst type of clickbait and just,
I mean it just is,
I don't even,
I'm not even,
but merging them,
that was,
that was just the game.
Then they taught us how to do the worst type of click made.
There's a reason why there's so many videos where it's like Ben Shapiro destroys
with logic and facts.
It's because that structure was working for the algorithm and it still does.
And uh,
for the most part,
the structure of like an all caps word,
um,
I do it too.
It's because,
um,
youtube finds it acceptable to just emphasize a word.
You can't do a bold,
but,
uh,
and you can't convey emphasis on words through tax without doing a capital or
something.
So that's a technique that works in the algorithm to get people to like pitch
the word and emphasis is important and conveying the meaning of your sentence.
So as long as,
yeah,
whatever.
All right,
so let's just do one other thing and then we'll get to the Q and.
A,
which is a piggy backing off what you just said so I can sense you're totally
okay.
Basically with what's going on here because you're growing,
like your business is growing,
you're doing journalism that you love.
You strike me as one of the only sort of journey.
Well,
while I was gonna say I'm,
I'm okay with that.
Well,
no,
but my point being is like we're watching all of the learn to code crowd that
was trying to get everybody,
all the trolls or whatever band.
It's like they're buzzfeed's laying off people.
Huffpo got rid of the editorial staff.
Vox is horrible.
Daily beast is crap.
Like all of these,
they're just giant monsters of crap who have lied to everybody for so long and
it's all,
nobody cares about any of it.
But what I'm watching right now,
and this is the reason I'm hopeful is a just by the very nature of what I'm
doing and I'm very proud of it and I think it's growing and it's good.
I think I see guys like you,
I see guys like Andy.
No.
Um,
uh,
Nick Monro on Twitter who does an interesting,
he's doing actual journalism.
He's leveraging Twitter for actual journalism.
I'm seeing people taking,
take technology,
use it their own way.
Peterson and I are working on this platform.
Like,
I think there's so much hopefulness here.
I've been this for you.
Yeah.
Give me some good news before we do the Q and,
and one of the main reasons youtube takes action against channels is because the
culture war.
These digital journalists who write these absurd stories put pressure on
advertisers and then you test it has to do something to stop the bleed.
As these companies lay more and more people off,
there's less people to write lies about us.
And that means youtube has less constrained.
So,
you know,
I,
I get really frustrated.
People point the finger at Youtube on things you took didn't do wrong.
Point the fingers at the things they did wrong.
I got Monkey Jones.
That was wrong.
But a lot of issues like the monetization you t people think demonetization is
someone at Youtube twirling their mustache on and take your money away.
It's like,
no,
no.
You took just lost their money to,
they don't want to do monetize if they don't have to,
but they're,
they're scared of these fringe identitarian Weirdos at this media companies who
want to call you and Ansel and Youtube is trying to do its best to make sure
here's this thing,
hit look.
You still get youtube red revenue when you can be monetized 100% that is youtube
putting up a barrier to protect you from these lunatics are lying about you.
So Youtube does things wrong.
Absolutely.
But they're doing better than a lot.
And I truly believe that once these companies collapse under the weight of their
own incompetence and other cultural problems,
I think youtube is going to be more free to be like you guys.
We got you.
You know,
so I mean look,
the fact that you're allowed to exist doing this,
you're,
you speak truth to power in a lot of ways.
You do things that would never be allowed by some of these people at these media
companies.
They never allow you to have certain people in here to talk about these things.
Youtube has opened the door and a lot of ways continues to.
Yeah,
and while they have mistakes,
I'm,
I'm hopeful because I know people at Youtube,
I've known them for years,
that they,
I think there is a,
there's absolutely an ideological bent to a lot of people.
I do have some sources that work within Google have shared information that I
don't think it's as bad as a lot of people think it is.
I think there's,
there's some points where it gets really bad the far left identitarianism within
the company,
but there's a lot of really hopeful in the area of free speech and protecting
rights that I think Google is aware of that other companies don't care about.
Yeah.
Well I'm glad to hear that.
That's a nice way to wrap up this first half they were doing here.
And I would just add to that that yeah,
I'm,
I'm incredibly appreciative of youtube looking like,
look,
my life is fucking amazing because of this.
Absolutely.
This is great.
I love detective,
right?
So when I'm fighting it and when,
and I always say,
I'm tired of fighting you guys.
And it's like,
give me,
I don't have an email address.
Give me,
you don't even know,
but you don't,
you know,
and it's like if you guys would just be a little bit better,
I think they'd get a lot.
I don't understand why at this point for you,
especially youtube doesn't just unlock everything.
Um,
like do they,
what do they think I'm going to do tomorrow?
Right.
No but,
but there,
there,
there have been conversations about giving people the option to choose the
amount of ties themselves.
Trusted,
trusted high profile.
Like your Dave Rubin.
Like they can look at your videos,
they know exactly what you're going to do and all these talk shows,
it is a talk show that is in line with almost any other kind of talk show you'd
see on TV that has normal advertisers.
I don't think there's going to be a big,
you know,
like you,
you're not even like Tucker Carlson who,
who has like activist coming at them cause you're,
you're not even anywhere near where he is.
So I'm surprised youtube hasn't come to you and says,
we think you're good to go,
period.
And they should.
I believe the system for you should be inverted.
It should be that right now your video gets the monetized.
You ask for a review.
What should happen is your video should be monetized and they should have to
choose to review you because you're trusted.
You're,
you're,
you're studio Dave Ruben.
Mainstream conversation professional.
But it is,
it's,
this is another thing too,
is it's important to recognize and hope youtube does too.
They need to create this protections because what you're doing is the,
is the new mainstream talk show,
right?
The television networks are doing really well,
but these digital outlets,
not so much.
Uh,
in a lot of ways,
this is the professional fee,
you know,
five,
seven years,
five to six,
seven years ago,
youtube didn't have this.
It had like,
I remember the first few I made,
it's like awful.
It's just so trashy.
Half a million views and that through,
did you know it's news,
but I had no idea what I was doing.
The quality was trash,
but I've got half a million views.
Yeah,
because youtube didn't have this.
Now,
youtube actually has,
there's a guy on youtube who does live high profile talk shows about political
issues that have serious ramifications on our culture and you've got a beautiful
set and you're not the only one.
So Youtube,
I'm sure they know this and at this point why,
why,
why is Seth Seth my uh,
what's,
who's the late night talk show hosts Seth Myers,
he's a preferred partner and you're not,
they give him special access.
They don't give you,
that's ridiculous that if youtube wants to see their platform grow,
then they need to start coming to people like you.
And they do this to,
to a lot of people,
but they absolutely need to comment and give special protections and,
and you know,
preferred access not just to the mainstream cable channel guys.
You know what I mean?
Now I owe you 5% of the monetization of this video if it gets monetized.
All right,
here's where we were to take a one minute break and then we're going to do super
chat questions.
Get them in right now.
We'll,
we'll read them live and do our thing for as long as we can.
Alright.
Hang tight.
[inaudible]
wow.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
all right,
we're back.
I think that was record time.
Yeah.
We paid in different bathrooms real fast.
That was,
yeah,
the magic way out the door.
No magic of youtube right here.
We go before anything else this Friday,
if you're in the La area,
uh,
I'm at the Ice House comedy club.
Uh,
it's Friday,
March 8th.
It's me.
Stand up,
mess around with the crowd audience Q and a.
Bring in an IDW member.
There's rumor that maybe 10 pool will be there.
Who the hell knows?
We'll see what happens.
Okay,
here we go.
I've got a zillion questions here.
Keep throwing them in on a,
on super chat.
We'll get to as many as possible.
Uh,
Tim,
you're an amazing example of journalistic integrity.
I'm glad your channels are getting traction.
The fact that you stuck to your principles,
even when thinking the feed was down was amazing.
Referencing the Rogan brand.
Do you think vagina was rep referencing abuse and harassment honestly,
or was this ideological doublespeak so a lot of people were frustrated with her
because she kind of talks like a lawyer and in the nature of the conversation
she is a lawyer and that makes it tough.
I think she believes what she was saying.
Um,
I think you like,
look,
when it comes to ideology,
I don't think Jack and vagina are lying about what they truly believe is right.
I just think they don't realize they're wielding a giant sword and no one ever
gave them that.
They have no rights to that power.
So yeah.
Is there an immediate plan for Twitter to remove lifetime bans and form a review
process where the SAR guns and Milo's of the world that seemed to have got
they,
they mentioned it being in the pipeline or something.
To me that sounds like it's never gonna happen.
Yeah.
You know,
it's too,
Tim,
I know you are a rather unassuming guy.
I'd like to say that you were a very good reporter and have unimpeachable
integrity.
Keep up the good work.
Not even a question.
I am a man who read nice things,
right?
I am not perfect.
Uh,
I,
you know,
I see all these things complimenting me.
I'm like,
I was just saying what I felt and I also feel like,
you know,
people like to call me objective and all these things.
Like,
dude,
I am,
I can,
I told Joe,
listen,
I'm a centrist partisan.
I clearly support certain values and integrities,
uh,
integrity and integral principles.
These are the things that led me to do journalism the way I do.
I don't want to act like I'm better than anybody else.
I Dunno.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh,
do you think Twitter should or does hire people like yourself that keep an ear
to the ground or a,
they can simply hire a team to intake media like yours?
There were many cases where they played ignorance to current events or cultural
events
out of that,
that it's just,
we don't know.
We're pushing.
Yeah.
I asked them,
why don't you open an office in a conservative area?
They said,
well,
our,
our trust and safety team is global.
I think ultimately what happens is they're trying to decide what is or isn't
right.
And they think they're smarter than 200 years of history and precedent set by
our institutions and our founding fathers and our ancestors.
They're not what they believe they are.
It's a level of arrogance that is,
in my opinion,
it's normal human arrogance and it takes a certain understanding of philosophy
to say,
I can never know what's right for,
for hundreds of millions of people.
I need to break up my power and disperse it.
Jack seems to understand this concept when he talks about distributed networks
and blockchain stuff and I wonder why then he won't say,
you know,
the power that the tri force of,
of,
of Twitter needs to be fractured and send out different directions.
That's what needs the power needs to be distributed.
It's too much for one person.
So you're saying that perhaps the distributed social network could be the
solution to some of this?
Um,
I'm,
we'll leave some people who were working on like,
is that what,
is that what I want,
I'm just reading questions here.
Just adding the thoughts that pop into my head,
but I,
but I will,
I will add,
that's been,
that's like,
I think you're in a race right now with a ton of other people that I'm like,
that's a beautiful thing.
I love that race right there.
There was diaspora.
Yup.
Uh,
if you're familiar with diaspora,
I mean people send me links to different and now we obviously mines is trying to
create,
it's a really interesting model.
It's a,
it's got a central nucleus with semi decentralized,
which could work.
And I've been using that for my group organizing,
so we'll see.
Yeah.
Well look,
that's a beautiful thing.
Let the competition go and then maybe some of them will end up merging.
Competition is a great little,
yeah,
that's what it's all about.
Uh,
thanks for the stream fellows.
Okay.
Uh,
Hey Ruben,
do you think,
uh,
oh.
Hey Ruben.
Hey Tim.
Do you think that Trump will ever do a live stream with a utuber also,
Tim,
thanks for your reporting.
Much appreciated.
I think eventually he will.
I think he's still like,
I hope he will come in here and it will be bananas and Oh my God,
if I ever thought I got hate,
it'll,
it'll raise it to a whole new level.
But my feeling is that eventually he's using the mainstream media as their
perfect rock and a hard place thing.
As long as he can.
And eventually something will shift,
the symmetry will shift and he'll have to do something.
Like the challenge for me is on Trump is like,
I can criticize them all day,
but the media literally does that nonstop 24,
seven.
I feel like I'm not adding anything to the conversation to point out why I agree
with why they criticize him.
Yeah.
I also think it's insane.
Trump derangement syndrome is a serious problem.
You can clearly look at the things he's done that are working and not be a
lunatic and you can like whatever.
I don't wanna get on Trump.
I will rant.
Um,
I worked for a major newly acquired tech company.
I'm a senior engineer.
Not many people are savvy to search algorithms.
How do we verify that our data is factual?
And an Arrow where our,
where our sensors are few but powerful.
I mean,
this comes up all the time,
right?
It's like,
oh,
it's,
you can,
I mean,
look,
I w y you know,
people,
you have a group of people who trust the mainstream media.
And Glenn Greenwald tweeted,
I feel sorry.
I genuinely feel sorry for the MSN.
You know,
he was referencing MSNBC viewers who for years have been told Trump was working
for Putin and all stuff.
And now that we're hearing the Mueller reports going to be anticlimactic and
there's probably nothing in it there.
They're losing their minds.
Like,
oh no,
our narrative.
What do you do?
Well,
you can't,
you,
you can't trust anybody.
It's insane.
I'm surprised.
I don't know what to tell you,
man.
Um,
it worries me.
I stay up at night sometimes.
Someone,
uh,
gave us four 99 in pounds on super chat and they said,
[inaudible] pool a drink on me.
Dude killed it on rogue.
And what do you,
what do you drink?
Not Alcohol.
You don't drink any alcohol?
Well,
I,
uh,
yesterday I had some beer after the Rogan thing and I had a deep fried Oreos
with ice cream.
So that was like,
that was fun.
We,
I went out and I had a beer and I didn't finish it.
I drank about half of it.
I can't,
I used to drink too much when I was young.
I just can't drink anymore.
It just doesn't work for me.
Well,
this is a Paleo House.
There are no Oreos in here,
but there is beer,
no beer.
You think about it,
chicken about it.
Like,
okay.
Satay peanut sauce or something.
Uh,
Tim,
I don't agree with your politics,
but I love how this discussion went or how your discussion went on.
Joe Rogan's podcast.
Well done,
sir.
A lot of,
but they're just saying nice things.
Um,
where are the people who ate me?
Let's see.
Okay,
the word fascist,
hence Nazi is among the fighting words not protected.
Does this change either of your minds about these terms a chip ski versus New
Hampshire?
I mean,
I,
I don't believe in hate speech period.
So I think with the exception of the very tiny,
tiny limitations on speech,
you can't yell fire in a crowded theater or quo coffered or direct violence.
I think you can do whatever you want.
So even though those guys were calling us and Nazi today,
I'm not actually for them getting booted.
The only reason I was sharing it was to show the idiotic double standards is
actually after the interview of yes.
If Twitter wants to claim they're trying to prevent us from leaving.
The only reason I haven't left Twitter is because I'm an adult who understands
the,
in the world people say mean things.
But there are some people who are not emotionally mature enough and I think
there's so according to the more in common document by the hidden tribe,
scraped knees and you have enough data,
progressive's are like 8% they're overwhelmingly white.
They tend to make more than twice as likely to make $100,000 per year.
What does that mean?
You've got a bunch of well off,
more likely to be well off white people who haven't been in the real world,
who are,
who have bulldozer parents who have cleared every obstacle out from in front of
them.
And when they go out in the real world,
they meet someone who says,
I just plain don't like you.
And they go,
oh,
it's a real offense to them.
They've never experienced that before.
Yeah,
I was homeless.
So I'll say this too.
When,
when it comes to like,
what if I got banned tomorrow when I,
when I went on a,
when I was on Rogan and I said,
the SPLC hope I hate chase bank is banning people is organizations are doing it.
And they could bend me too.
I don't care.
You know what happened if I got banned on every platform right now,
I'd go,
I'd go kick on the beach,
have a coconut and be like,
ah.
I,
I would,
I would honestly be like,
I'm glad it's finally over.
I can relax.
I am,
uh,
a hippie at heart,
lefty libertarian,
and I want to sit on in the middle of nowhere under some trees with the coconut
and some buddies and just,
you know,
making our own fire,
finding her own food.
And I just want to be left alone.
And I have an unfortunate,
something in my head where I'm passionate to,
to fight for these values in our society.
I have told myself this since I was like 18.
The moment it becomes too difficult,
I am gone.
And it's just been this ongoing passionate drive I've kept,
kept going and kept working.
And now for some reason I was just in front of Jack Dorsey,
the CEO of Twitter.
Who the hell am I to sit in front of this multimillionaire,
billionaire?
Whatever is worth while you're somebody doing what you're supposed to do.
I'm just a guy talks about stuff,
you know,
it's like,
but this is what you're supposed to be doing.
That's what the event and,
but,
and I'll say it again,
if,
if they all said,
you know what,
Tim,
we're going to ban you out.
Right?
I'd be like,
man,
I'd get my car and I would just,
Oh my God,
you know,
let me tell you,
it sounds so awesome that some days I'm like,
man,
I can't stop.
I have to work.
I haven't taken a day off in two years,
but sometimes I'm like,
the only way I could stop as if they force me to,
that'd be so great.
I'd go stay at the skate park for a week.
Just play some music with an acoustic guitar out under the stars.
Used to put you out of your [inaudible] knock you out of my misery.
Not Good.
Um,
hey Dave and Tim loved the work you guys do.
Tim,
do you plan to report on the SNC Lavaline scandal in Canada?
I actually don't know what that is.
I don't know about it,
but that reminds me of something,
I'm sorry,
I can't answer that question,
but I did want to point something out,
I forgot about earlier when it came to why you can't regulate tech companies
into inventing things.
Canada passed a bill that would require Google to create a registry of,
you know,
political ads.
So go that.
Okay.
And terminated all political ads.
Yeah.
You can't invent something.
So I apologize,
I can't answer that,
but you know.
Okay.
Um,
do you feel that the actors that you guys mentioned earlier actually hold those
leftist opinions or do you feel that they are forced to espouse those opinions
by their publicist out of desire to look like the good guy?
You know,
there's a piece of me that when I,
when I saw the,
uh,
the thing with Brie Larson,
you know,
at the award leaving,
I actually sort of felt like she knows the movie's not gonna do well.
So it's like,
what do you do?
You get in front of it by making now a comment that's going to claiming as the
trolls are.
Yep.
So you,
so it's like,
it wasn't that the movie wasn't good.
She Shit,
they destroyed me.
Like she walked it back a song.
I think,
I think the issue is there is a youtube are made of steel.
It might've been pissed after exactly.
A really school,
uh,
youtube or made a video where Michael B.
Jordan is on the view and they're asking a black panther and he says,
you know,
look,
we're just here to celebrate who we are.
We're not trying to bring anybody down.
And he brings up out in South Korea,
a bunch of other people from Indonesia.
I'll shut up in traditional clothing,
and it was really uplifting and everyone was happy.
And this year too,
where is like,
green check mark,
like,
oh,
that made me feel really good when Michael B.
Jordan said that we're celebrating who we are with each other.
That's so awesome.
That's,
it's a,
it's a small world after.
All right.
So Disney is saying,
unhappy Brie Larson does the head Bob,
this is will be wasn't made for you.
And I'm like,
oh,
whoa.
Why are you doing?
Like,
that's mean?
And then she,
she,
she also has a bunch of tweets where she's like a Tsh.
I simply looked at a TSA agent,
he has my phone number,
and I'm like,
oh,
come on,
man.
Like,
dude,
yeah,
I get it,
but can you please get adult?
Yeah.
Uh,
four liberals on Rogan debating whether Twitter is sensitive sensory and
conservatives and no conservative invited to the discussion.
Really,
really good points is how censored we are.
Yep.
But,
but that's a actually,
I actually really,
really good point.
I have no,
I have no response other than Yep.
I mean,
but look,
it was,
it was authoritarian,
left versus libertarian.
Laughs talking about the banning of Libertarians.
And I don't mean big a libertarian.
So I think one of the things I should clarify too is the debate isn't about
conservatives are the most mostly getting the brunt of this,
but there are libertarian left.
It's,
it's really about the authoritarian left.
There's no real authoritarian,
right.
Other than like,
um,
well,
I don't want to name any of the mainstream politicians who fall into that
category.
That's Democrats too.
I'm not pointing,
I don't even,
I don't even know who that would be really.
I'm not going to say it,
but it's,
it's,
it should be fairly obvious.
The mainstream corporatist Democrats,
they're authoritarian,
right.
As far as I'm concerned,
they've always been,
they are not in line with Bernie Sanders.
They hate Bernie Sanders.
They hate Tulsi Gabbert.
They hate the left libertarian people who want to end the foreign wars.
So you know,
anybody who was in favor of taking corporate money taking $300,000 from Goldman
Sachs,
but right before they announced so they can use that money and they're in favor
of military,
industrial,
complex foreign bombing,
another country's that's authoritarian.
Right.
And that includes Democrats and Republicans.
Fair enough.
Yeah.
Um,
what is worth someone like Alex Jones who you know's exaggerating on things,
uh,
or buzzfeed who lie but pretend to be honest and the good guys feel free to come
back to Australia anytime.
I gladly will.
I think we're going to do it next year.
Uh,
Alex Jones made a statement that was read out by vagina that I believe was
indefensible.
He said he was encouraged to be able to do things politically and even
criminally and get your battle rifles ready.
And I understand,
you know,
if,
if it's supposed to be a joke or metaphorical or whatever,
but he did say it and you have to recognize there's,
he's got a huge audience.
People will take that literally and he can't do that.
However,
that was an x one stream action.
Buzzfeed is doing haymakers I did a video on my youtube channel where I
explained what,
what,
what you've got an uppercut,
a powerful boom to the face.
And then buzzfeed doing small jobs over and over again.
Buzzfeed was on the Covington,
you know,
BS,
buzzfeed.
Even after it was proven.
Their story about Michael Cohen and Trump was wrong so far.
So first of all,
that went away quick,
didn't it?
None of that.
They want to keep defending it.
Mueller Mueller came out and said,
the story is fake.
What is must we do?
Nope.
We stand by our sources.
Cohen testifies Trump never directly told me to lie.
It doesn't work that way.
Nope,
we were right.
It's like,
you know,
I mean,
I mean it went away.
Not that the story went away.
I mean that it just,
nobody really called them out with the left.
She was like check.
Cause it was,
it happened on a Friday and by Monday it was basically over.
It's,
and so,
you know,
I'm,
I'm curious and I mentioned this to,
uh,
it's one of the problems with bias,
right?
Uh,
I think Jackson,
good guy,
I think he's trying,
they didn't know who Johnathan Morgan was.
They knew who Jacob Wall was.
Why?
Because the journal journalists are like eight.
It's something like 72% of journalism jobs are in blue districts,
so they're like,
Ooh,
Jacob Wall,
Jonathan Morgan,
a democrat.
They don't,
well,
you know,
even though he duped them,
even though this guy,
it's reported by the New York Times that he was engaging in this operation,
Facebook banned him for,
I think it's fair to say this happened,
was manipulating national reporters and to smearing or Republican.
They still just kind of like,
they do,
they report on it.
That's fair.
But where was the outrage from the whole Twitterati all the digital media saying
are the Democrats are meddling in our election.
Oh my God.
Nap.
Yeah.
Did any of the uh,
verified journalists or politicians or whatever who were calling for violence or
punched those kids in the face or any of those?
Did any of them that get banned or suspended?
So I,
the only thing I can comment on is the,
the one guy I referenced over and over again who said lock him in school,
burnt down fire on them when you see them.
He did get a suspension and was forced to delete those tweets.
But I think it's absolutely hilarious that you can have someone like Chuck
Johnson where he said he was raising money to take out,
you know,
deray and they're like,
oh better banned him perma ban,
no warning.
Just done.
And there was a,
I could be wrong,
but I believe there was a story about email leaks where like some up an
individual was like just to get rid of him.
Then you have the,
this other guy who was like,
lock them in school,
bring it down.
No.
Well please don't do this again,
please like calling for the death the kids versus insinuating you want to raise
money to do a hit piece on an individual that was,
could be construed in a certain way.
I get it.
I would have had no problem with.
They said,
listen,
do you understand why people might think you're talking about killing somebody?
Can you take this down and,
oh,
okay.
Sorry about that.
No,
they were like whack this other guy.
Just please just,
we'll stop on.
Oh,
Lordy,
lordy.
All right guys.
We're going to get to as many as possible.
Just a reminder,
I am at the Ice House in Pasadena,
right here in La.
March 8th it's this Friday.
Maybe Tim will be there.
Maybe an IDW.
No,
I promise you an Ibw guy.
I'll either,
maybe 10 will be there.
I assume the link is right down below,
so check that out.
Or it's Dave rubin.com/events.
Okay,
here we go.
My birthday is the following day too,
so it's,
yeah.
Oh,
well,
yeah,
this changes everything.
That's why I'm staying in La for the weekend.
You know,
I don't,
I don't know.
How old are you going to be?
33 33rd birthday in La.
Three three this could ever,
you could end up with the coconut and just go off the grid.
That's how it all and all right,
here we go.
Uh,
although vagina was forthcoming,
did you detect any tactical dishonesty in how she spoke?
Bows?
Worse damage control,
especially in comparison to Jackson.
Absolutely.
Like when I brought up learn to code,
they prepared for it and she said it was connected to harassment campaigns on a
whole and then,
and that's why there's only a couple of times I actually stopped her and like in
anger,
I apologized for it because,
but I'm like,
I have to,
you know,
I want to give them time to answer because I didn't want to just start leveling
all these things and throwing them.
I wanted them to explain themselves,
be fair.
But when she went back on,
well,
it was a harassment.
I'm no,
no,
no.
The editor in chief of the daily caller was not harassing anybody who's tweeting
a joke and you locked him out of his account.
There is no explanation for that.
And following the episode with Joe,
I got inundated with emails of people showing me that even when they were
tweeting to their friends,
someone responded to a conservative personality.
They said,
Loi,
this is a really great thing.
And they may,
maybe this could help someone learn to code spending just joking at it.
Yet they're basically,
because basically I think what Twitter did was they were lobbied by activists,
activists who work for news organizations.
They say it's not true,
but I'm like,
I,
journalists were targeted in the first place,
um,
by people saying,
learn to code.
I can't imagine that wasn't the case.
And they said,
just band everybody who's just an algorithm that,
you know,
just,
yeah.
All right.
I'm calling it a lot of blood for a second because,
so we talked about the,
uh,
just sort of the business model of the media companies and why they are
criminally,
but what do you make it just the general state of journalists in general.
Like I mentioned some of the journalists I like,
but there,
there are so many,
these people that work at these companies.
I mean,
let,
you could never have another job.
Like they could never,
they don't have a job in the first place.
Don't really.
Yeah.
You know,
I used to work for American,
I worked for American Airlines region.
I'll tell American Eagle lifting,
I believe around something like 50,000 pounds per day.
Um,
I part my hand at one point during this labor,
I was making 10 bucks an hour.
And then when I,
for the first time,
walked into a newsroom,
I went,
how much are they getting paid per year?
You're getting more than double what I got to write about Brad Pitt's junk.
Yeah.
What is,
and then they're saying they're not getting paid enough.
And I'm like,
wow,
you know,
vice a notoriously underpaid people,
but I never really thought of it much because I was like,
you're upset that you're getting 30 grand a year.
Like I was getting 13 to lift bags and be insulted and do backbreaking labor
covered in sweat all day.
This is paradise and that's another reason why I'm like,
I,
you really have no leverage over me.
These people,
if they're threatening me with banning,
I really don't care.
You could take away my shoes,
my pants,
and I have.
I have seen the worst of the worst I have.
I have been to the favelas of Brazil.
I have been to the old communist bloc housing in Ukraine.
I have seen how bad things can really be an all I look at when I see the beauty
and comfort of America is spoiled brats who are complaining about how bad they
have it when they have it better than 99% of the world.
It's mind blowing to me.
Free his country,
the history of the world,
that bed,
Tim,
I'm so proud of you.
You stood your ground and held their feet to the fire.
Dave,
love you to fight on.
All right.
That's okay.
And then another one I love.
Well,
here's the deal.
We got three.
I love,
he's in a row that was just,
I love you.
Love you.
Tim.
Been amazing to see your rise.
Please both of you keep defending free speech and expression.
Okay.
Um,
thanks for doing this important job.
This is an interesting one for you.
Who would win in a tag team wrestling match.
Ben Shapiro and Jordan Peterson,
verse Dave Rubin and Eric Weinstein.
Uh,
you and Eric,
um,
I'm not trying to be a Dick,
but Ben Shapiro is on the smaller yeah,
but no,
it's true.
I mean,
but Jordan's got long reach.
He's got long reach,
but then you're,
uh,
you're,
you're a little taller than average,
so you could,
you could probably easily counter against Jordan if you put some,
you know,
but,
but Eric is got the,
the,
the curb weight he could easily crush,
man.
Yeah,
he's,
he,
yeah,
he's got the white claw,
his way out classes.
You know,
both.
So I think you guys together,
it's an unfair,
you know,
the memes are already coming out.
Oh,
this is a good one.
and I actually,
I was going to ask you this,
but I only saw about 80% of the whole thing yesterday cause I didn't realize it
was on until I have to click your bed store.
Why didn't you ask about why Louis Farrakhan's account is allowed?
Man,
I,
you know,
I'll be honest,
there was a bunch of stuff that just,
I didn't get to,
I had notes and I was checking them too.
And there was just,
I felt like there was so much and at a,
at a certain point too,
he's,
they've addressed it and I don't know,
there,
there were a couple of people that afterwards I was like,
God,
that's a really good point.
You know,
I just,
I'm not perfect.
A lot of people thought that I wasn't the right person for the job.
Um,
I look,
I see a lot of people praising you.
You're like,
wow,
Tim was perfect for this.
Some people are strapped saying,
Ben Shapiro should've been the right person.
And I'm like,
yeah,
maybe.
I don't know.
I,
when Joe give mean conservative people that we were saying from the conservative
side thing,
you weren't being hard enough.
Yeah,
I actually didn't see any of that.
Uh,
there were there comments from people and even like,
you know,
I'll say this too,
it seems like Sam Harris has fans absolutely tested me.
I don't know,
whatever.
Uh,
but there are conservative people who thought it would've been better if Ben
Shapiro was there instead.
Because,
you know,
maybe,
I don't know.
I think Ben Shapiro is really good at what he does and it's a good point that
he's a conservative and I'm not.
Um,
while I certainly have tracked a of this news,
maybe that would have made more sense.
All I can say is I got asked to do it and my response to,
to Joe was,
Joe,
I'm a little burned up in a tree that just got us down feathers and you're
kicking me out of the nest right now by asking me to do this.
I'll do it.
And he was like,
yeah,
come on man.
He's like,
you're a smart guy.
And I'm like,
let's go,
you know,
so
beautiful thing.
Just doing what you're supposed to be doing,
I guess.
Yeah.
Love both y'all.
I'm a conservative and I have many strong political differences with you guys,
but I appreciate both of you for your dedication and seeking the truth rather
than promoting politically convenient narratives.
Right on.
Thank you.
Maybe the conspiracy is some organization created the regressive left to unify
depth,
like ma,
like you're moderate liberal and conservatives and to allying
good.
Why do I keep getting invited to conservative things where I go up there,
I tell them all these things that I disagreed with them and they keep inviting
me back.
It's very bizarre,
you know?
I mean,
really,
if me and you said,
well,
let's try it right now.
If,
if,
uh,
if a progressive,
organization and not to mock us or to whatever would invite us to a,
to a university or something,
would you do it?
Absolutely.
All right.
So let's see.
Maybe somebody will invite us,
but yeah,
probably not.
Um,
has anyone looked into the contractor's Twitter uses to moderate tweets?
Jack mentioned also the other social media companies use the same ones.
Could be,
could that be part of the bias?
You know,
there was an interesting moment where he said the thing about they're looking
into allowing the user to have control of whether the responses could be seen.
And I thought that was interesting because what I notice is now that now that
I'm high profile,
every time I tweet,
I could tweet a picture of my dog and I get a million people in.
They're telling me I'm a,
I'm a Nazi and the rest of it and you can,
and they know that the worst that they are to me,
the more likes it gets.
So the idea of shutting down replies I think is,
is interesting.
But,
but then he,
he sort of walked it back cause then he said no,
we would let the users have to click an extra click.
Right.
That's so,
so basically they're trialing the system where when you tweet and someone
responds,
you can mute them.
So no one can see it unless you go to the bottom and then like open up the muted
posts or whatever.
Right.
So I guess there's something valuable there.
Right here.
Here's a,
you can sort of push it down then I guess Twitter,
the problem with Twitter is,
is how do you get rewarded on Twitter?
Anger.
Yeah.
Insults.
So I know some,
some people who are,
they used to be regular journalists.
There's a guy I used to work with,
uh,
when I would do some guest hosting for a certain network and he was a normal
dude.
We got along,
we have basically the same politics.
And then he realized he gained followers by replying to Donald Trump.
And what did he do now it's like,
I look at his Twitter and I'm like,
what the Hell is wrong with you?
Like that's,
I mean for sure they say the same thing to me.
But admittedly I think it's funny when they,
uh,
to move into another point when they're like,
Tim,
you changed.
They claim on being red.
Pilled and then I made a video where I was like,
here's an article for 2012 from 2012 where I was calling up black bloc
anarchists for getting violent and they physically attacked me.
You want to tell me?
My opinions have changed.
I'm sure many of them have.
Absolutely.
I look at my videos,
but you can also go 2012 and see,
I have always been at odds with these people.
They hate my guts.
They physically attack me numerous times,
aren't occupy because I believe in being,
I'll tell you exactly what happened.
I filmed some people draining the out of a tire wasn't intentional.
I didn't seek them out.
I just saw him and I filmed it.
They came to me later and said,
if you don't produce propaganda for us,
we will stop you.
They wanted me specifically to film the things they would point to like only
filmed the police don't feel,
must let us do our thing.
And I said no,
I'm going to let people know exactly what's happening.
So they did.
I was a tech several times and it's,
it's been,
it's like to think that there are people who are like,
I don't understand why Tim is calling out Antifa.
Oh No.
It's like,
hey,
have you ever watched anything I've ever done?
Like we there,
there,
there's a,
there's an article about me in like some magazine was a picture of me being held
back by cops while I was fighting a guy in black bloc in 2011 and come on man.
Well,
so the idea that you've been putting all of that aside,
the idea that you're not allowed to evolve or change your opinion.
Oh,
exactly.
Sad.
And,
and,
and like somebody,
there was a recently a video where it was like,
Dave Rubin's opinion changing over time and people are gasping.
And I'm like,
so you took old videos of Reuben and then you realize that as he got older he
read things and changes opinion that doesn't,
well,
how was that in writing them?
Literally every week for the last five years as I've changed on things.
I've talked about it openly like,
but you don't,
you don't really bothers me about,
uh,
I,
I think,
look,
I'll be honest,
I think there's absolute criticism that you can be criticized for.
I think you're,
I'm not Jesus.
Right,
exactly.
Criticize the hell out of me.
I remember watching one of your videos.
You had someone who was like,
I'm very much like on the left and social justice and I was watching it and then
like shortly after I saw someone say that they posted a link to like an older
interview did with like,
you know Jordan Peterson and they said all Reuben ever does is talk to
conservatives.
And I was like,
you know what unit it is?
They do the same thing to me.
They only share these videos and they assume you're not talking to people.
And I'm like,
go to his channel,
just click videos.
I went there,
I'm like,
who is this?
oh that person's like kind of on the left.
Someone broke it down once on Facebook.
They took literally every interview I've ever done and it actually leaned,
mostly left.
It's like a split between like slightly left in a little bit libertarian.
And they,
they do the same thing to me where they'll take select videos and then be like,
look at this video,
Tim dead.
And I'm like,
did you watch it?
You know?
So actually a really good example of this back when I'm comedy was watching.
You don't want them to watch as a really good point.
When Comey was testifying a couple of years ago,
he uh,
I made the video titled Did,
did uh,
did James Call me lie under oath question mark because conservatives are saying
he did.
Liberals were saying,
of course not,
and my liberal friends were outraged that I would dare make a video accusing him
of lying.
I didn't.
In fact the video concludes he likely didn't.
And here's why.
The reason I post it as a question was so that I was neutral to both factions.
I'm not going to tell you what he did or didn't do.
I'm going to ask the question if you're interested,
I can then walk you to why I believe a certain thing.
They were upset that I didn't make a video outright defending them even though I
did.
Yeah.
They wanted the title to definitively say conservatives are stupid.
James Comey is not a lie around like it was a really neutral title,
but they got angry about it.
Bow Forever,
man.
Or they're not going to stay with you as a fellow south sider.
I watch your shows because you reminds me of hanging out with my buddies at the
park.
What parks did you hang out at?
Keep up the great work.
Both of them.
They don't,
they don't park southwest side of Chicago.
And um,
Westlawn uh,
Tim,
I'm so proud of you.
You stood your ground and held their feet to the fire.
Dave,
love you to fight on.
Okay.
We've got another just generic.
I love you.
Thank you.
Thanks for doing this.
Important job.
Thank you.
We already did the wrestling one.
Let me scroll the other way.
Um,
Kudos for yesterday's podcast.
Question.
Is there any politician openly discussing anti monopoly laws in the digital
space?
I'm looking at Twitter,
Facebook,
Google,
Amazon,
and their kin de facto monopolies.
Well,
I guess I'm not sure.
I think,
I think you know when,
when,
when jump is kind of talking about it,
right?
But I,
I feel like jump Trump Trump gets his opinions and from Fox News,
like you literally will tag Tucker Carlson and Hannity after he hears them.
And I,
I look,
I gotta be honest.
I don't blame him.
I don't expect him.
He's a president and he's going,
he's doing work.
Yeah,
the left has,
wants to apply.
He's not doing work,
but I'm sure at the end of the day turns on the news.
That's what he hears.
And then he tweets about it.
So He's,
he's a few steps behind the rest of us.
So I think he is concerned.
He mentioned the executive order on free speech on campuses.
I've seen,
uh,
I think,
um,
Jonathan Haidt was critical of it,
but by Weinstein was positive.
So there's,
there's some debate here,
but when I saw Jack Dorsey testifying before Congress,
they had no idea with how they're talking about.
There was like one good interview where the guy said,
why is Twitter defaulting only democratic politicians when you sign up in DC?
And Jack was like,
uh,
I don't know.
Well that's also,
but that's also why to me regulation that we don't have to get back into it.
But it's like,
that's why that makes some sense.
The idea that the government could understand what a tech company would have to
do.
Like I pay my property taxes on a California state website.
It looks like prodigy 1996 you're like that.
They'd come in and be like,
we know the tech,
Twitter,
Twitter is Twitter as much government.
Twitter is much easier to regulate because in terms of when you first sign up,
you get recommended Democrats.
They could say,
okay,
get rid of that because that's favoring one side.
If he can't solve the solution,
get rid of it.
When it comes to actual content on Twitter,
it's a reverse chronological feed.
You can still follow whoever you want.
You'll see what they post when they post it.
Well that's assuming they're not shadow banning and doing a bunch of others.
That's what I mean.
We have reasoning,
so if that's the,
if the regulation is Twitter,
you must abide by free speech as set forth by this as,
as as a precedent set forth by the Supreme Court.
Therefore,
you know,
if something is illegal law enforcing,
we'll take care of it.
It'll be taken down with a lot,
like,
you know,
a lawful order or whatever that could,
that could,
that could work because Twitter doesn't have any more,
that's not super complicated.
They are trying to do algorithmic feeds,
which I think is a bad idea of global idea.
No.
Jeez.
All right.
Um,
do either of you agree with radios banding Michael Jackson now in the wake of
leaving?
Other than that,
so it hasn't,
it's Neverland.
I haven't seen it yet.
Yeah,
I haven't seen it.
I mean,
I've heard we knew,
I mean south park and how many episodes where Michael Jackson was like,
you know,
doing weird things with the kids.
Like,
you know,
separate that from the artists.
Do I think Brie Larson is snooty?
I do.
Um,
is that the reason why I chose to skip Captain Roberts?
We're going,
it's not,
it's because you combine that with the marketing of the film and I was worried
I'd sit through another last Jedi.
Yeah.
So you know,
with Chris Evans,
I really don't like the things he posts.
He comes off as someone who thinks he's smart and he's not like he was,
he uses obscure small words to make it seem like it's got a big vocabulary.
Are you telling me he could possibly be worse than Rafal?
Cause Ruffalo is unbearable.
And I told him really the hope.
Now I'm like Ah,
but,
but you know,
I separate the from narratives.
So my job was terrible.
And look,
you know,
when you go back in time and start making,
getting,
you know,
raising your arms and wiggling in the air because maybe it's called outside as
offensive today.
You know what I think it is?
Honestly,
it's because,
uh,
the far left and right mean different things depending on what you're talking
about.
Economics or culture,
far left and far right often are used to refer in most instances I believe
traditional versus progressive.
So the far left,
the extremists and progressive culture want to purge history.
It's,
it's what,
it's what I believe that is in China.
What does,
I don't remember what it was.
Um,
the culture evolution,
I think where they're like,
let's get rid of the old and build the new.
So they want to purge baby,
it's cold outside.
They want to get rid of old songs because they were offensive.
Even though we understand the era of and we've gotten rid of these things.
It's also the height of pomposity to think that all,
I mean you,
you said this earlier basically,
but to think that the thousands of years of human history that it was also wrong
and,
but you,
you have somehow gained the insight,
well all those morons before you couldn't figure out and if only you had the
power over.
This is one of my favorite points to make in this conversation.
The,
in the,
uh,
in English common law we have the presumption of innocence and that's actually,
that's actually in the Bible.
So when you look at where society is today and one of the most important tenants
of a free society,
liberal democracy in our English common law,
the idea that we would say it is better that 10 guilty persons escape than one
innocent suffer is not an original idea from Blackstone.
It's bites on formulation.
It's actually biblical in the story of Sodom and Gomorrah.
And I believe his name was lot.
I,
uh,
so there's a lot of people I know on the left where like the Bible is Hokey bs.
It's like,
I agree a lot of it is,
but also don't forget,
a lot of our institutions today started there and brought us to a certain point.
The story was simple.
God was going to destroy Sodom and Gomorrah.
And he said,
for the sake of 50 righteous people,
I want to destroy it.
And then he asked,
what about 30,
what about 20?
And God said,
even for one righteous person,
I will not destroy the city.
And that taught us a long time ago.
That Bible,
the,
the old,
the old testament is full of crazy things we do not want to employ today.
And modern religions don't like modern Judaism and Christianity do not adhere to
like stoning people.
But we do still maintained the presumption of innocence and the right,
the protecting the righteous,
you know,
meet even if it means all the bad people get to go free.
So the point I want to make is we built our society.
We haven't,
we haven't just destroyed everything in our wake.
We're not burning the bridge behind us.
We're getting rid of the bad things and keeping the good things and there are
people that are so extreme to the left,
they want to destroy everything.
Baby.
It's cold outside is a classic song.
We understand why it can make some people angry,
but for the most part it really doesn't.
It's fake outrage.
Yeah.
You know,
and they want to get rid of it until like we can keep these things.
And the other important issue is to,
when it comes to the,
like the statute debate of confederate statues,
I usually take a rather centrist approach.
Why don't we put it in a museum and then put a placard there explaining what
history was and why we changed it.
Because then you maintain your history,
the stat sectors in a museum where people can still learn about their history
and then people can say,
we've changed as a society,
but we always need to remember our past.
I think that's a very unfair position I would be for,
you could just put,
you could even leave them there in some cases and still put the statue,
but at least,
or you know,
put up,
put up a plaque of explaining there.
There's a,
uh,
looney tunes,
I think it was,
maybe it was Disney.
A cartoon was up on Youtube of historical cartoons that were like black face and
really offensive.
And there's a disclaimer saying,
please remember,
this was from a different time and we understand why these things are offensive
and wrong,
and to pretend like this didn't exist,
which would be to pretend our racist history also didn't exist.
And we don't want to do that.
I agree.
Yeah,
absolutely agree.
Well also it's that they'll come for everything.
You know,
the creators we have really guide now are saying they're not going to make gay
jokes anymore.
So what do you,
well,
you're not going to engage with whether you still going to make black jokes or
you can still look and make Jew jokes and what can we do?
You know,
they,
they're not doing it.
And who decided they're right in the sense that they are that I think,
do they flip on that?
Well,
I think it was fake news actually.
It was fake news that they're getting rid of poo in the company.
The producers were like,
oh no,
no,
we're not what you're talking about,
dear God,
I hope you're right.
But here's,
here's the thing.
When the story broke,
they were gonna get rid of Arpu.
Yeah.
There was actually a backlash among the regressive left.
I don't wanna say the regressive left,
but social justice activist saying,
you're getting rid of a strong migrant business owner.
Like Apu wasn't a negative stereotype.
He was a successful business owner about immigration.
He was homeless,
friend yelled,
he was.
He's actually the heart of that and there's a whole freaking town.
There's an episode about a proposition to send him home and it became a citizen
so quick.
A lot of,
exactly.
A lot of people were like,
here you have one of the most positive depictions of an Indian American migrant
who successfully runs a business and because some people are upset by it,
they're going to get rid of it when some people actually appreciate it.
Yeah.
I'm curious though,
we'll have to just Google this after,
but I think they said it was real because then Hank Azaria said he won't do the
voice anymore because they got to him and he's a white guy even though he's the
greatest,
you know,
voiceover actor of a generation,
as you said,
I shouldn't have done it or I won't do,
they don't get,
they never returned the money.
Right.
So he's not returning all the games.
I'll do one more on that issue.
You know why fake news will never stop money.
You publish fake news story.
You make all the money.
You wish your attraction two days later,
you keep all the money.
Yeah.
All right.
Uh,
okay.
Let's do a,
we'll do two more.
Uh,
Tim made a point about how people are scared about appearing racist and jumping
ship to other platforms.
This may be a double edged sword that breeds SJW thinking for the people who
stay on Twitter over compensating for their anti racism resulting in shoe color
equals racist.
That's actually pretty interesting.
Like w so the idea is that you don't want to leave to go to say gap or something
like that,
that people will say you're racist.
So then you stay on Twitter and then over time I suppose you sort of get dumbed
down into just now you still want clicks,
so then you just do what you gotta do it again.
I don't know what,
what I do if I'm understanding the question probably,
but I do know is that gap is growing.
Dissenter is dissenter is I got to say,
you know dissenters brilliant.
Don't descend Torres.
I know it just came out through the,
it's a browser extension that creates a comment section for any website.
And when I heard they were doing that,
I went,
Whoa,
that was really,
really smart.
It's so simple.
Now there is an issue in that the value of Twitter for me is the news feed.
They don't care about the stupid opinions of the crazy people.
But seeing the breaking news is really important for me.
It's one of my sources.
So Gab doesn't work for that.
Gab Gab is good for the people who use Gab.
And I also want to stress too,
I don't care for the fake news.
Uh,
the best I could understand is that when I did my research,
a study was done,
found gabs hate speech is about 5% of all posts.
Twitter as,
as 2.4 somewhere in those numbers gap is not that much worse.
And my understanding is it's predominantly like Trump supporters.
They got bad actors for sure.
Yeah.
Twitter has substantially more bad actors.
That weird thing when the,
when the guy shot up the the temple and uh,
was that Not Philadelphia?
Oh,
the Twitter user.
Yeah.
I'm blanking.
The Twitter user who did it?
[inaudible] he was a Twitter user,
but they,
but all stories were about his gab again,
because he was also a gap user.
Right.
That was the point I was trying to make.
He was on Twitter.
Who's on Facebook,
you know?
Yeah.
All right.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna ask a deep dark one right now to end this thing,
but then we'll try to end it in a little positive.
No,
but I do get this question often that public or things to please Tim.
Do you,
do you think,
uh,
we could be looking at a potential civil war or information where,
I mean,
I guess we're in it.
Well,
the inflammation wars happening.
Yeah.
That's why I date and society's lying about us.
But I think it's really funny when I mentioned,
you know,
cause I'll,
I'll absolutely say yes,
there's going to be some kind of civil war.
We may be in it.
And um,
it's funny,
most people don't freak out because they understand,
I'm not like a prepper.
I'm not saying that we're going to be,
you know,
all the buildings will be destroyed and it'll be like Syria.
I'm saying there's gonna be some kind of insurgency.
You know,
we had the guys show up at the school in Eugene,
Oregon,
smash the Patriarchy and chill,
pull that a concealed gun,
fire two rounds at a cop a week later.
Protesters at the far left came and said,
you killed our comrade.
A week later someone planted a bomb at a police station.
You made a good point by the way that these things were extremely underreported
because Oh,
absolutely.
Theme there.
They were all coming from the left and then when the guy planted the bomb and in
Houston on a statue and then tried to act like it wasn't by drinking the
explosive,
the liquid,
you know,
he's using for it.
So we had the escalation of violence.
We have people marching through the streets with guns.
We now have far left and uh,
yes to an extent,
far right groups that it's actually,
I'll say this,
I,
I'm,
I'm not super familiar with the far right groups that are prominent and
marching.
There are right wing groups that are marching around and libertarian groups,
but you do have far left communist factions that are armed and marching around.
One important point though is that I have seen people associated with the left
and the right who are,
who have guns at and they have more respect for each other than anyone else.
So it was an interesting thing.
I saw a rally in Texas.
There was a guy that was a left wing protesters here to right wing protests are
both armed and they were laughing and smiling at each other asking about,
you know,
because I think the gun give them a common connection.
They were,
they understood the importance of the training,
the discipline,
what the point I want to make is,
uh,
I think we're going to see some kind of insurgency people point to the weather
underground and say,
we had this before my understanding of the weather underground.
It was,
it was shocking.
It was late night.
No,
people were around while someone planted a bomb at a police station in Eugene,
Oregon.
And they,
it was real.
And it was during the day when people were there and the guy mowing the lawn saw
it.
They had to come in and deal with it.
Um,
you know,
we,
so I think the,
the,
the nightmare scenario for me is for one,
what are we seeing right now?
Chase Bank,
shutting people down?
Only a couple of counts so far.
Mastercard has shot a couple.
Uh,
I believe at least one person,
maybe more,
I could be wrong.
Patrion Twitter banning people are moving to Gab,
but people are moving to mind as people are moving to other platforms bit.
Shoot.
So I've,
I've,
I talked about the emergence of a parallel society on Twitter,
at least right now.
Like Jack Dorsey mentioned Megan Phelps,
the Westboro Baptist Church got to interact with people and it pulled her out of
the church they're doing away with that.
They are guaranteeing that uh,
the way it was,
it was actually explaining this,
so I mentioned this,
but it was Joey salads,
the youtuber who went through that whole redemption process.
He said,
when you ban people,
you're taking like some dude who just smokes pot and putting them in prison with
some murderers.
Like what do you think is going to do to those people?
So you've got someone on Twitter who was banned for saying men aren't women,
and then they're like your band.
The only place they can go is where there's actual white supremacists and Nazis.
What do you think is going to happen to those people when they're surrounded by
this?
And it's the only community that engages with them.
And that's why,
uh,
I liked,
I like telling the story of Joe.
I did an interview with him recently when,
uh,
if you,
you know,
Joey sales is,
he did that video where you hired black people to smash your Trump card.
It's horrible,
horrible,
terrible,
terrible thing to do.
And when he tweeted at me the first time,
I got so angry this fake news guy,
cause he represented the fake news people,
I hated so much doing the same thing.
And then I realized this guy is trying not to be that guy anymore.
If I don't let him,
he's going to go back to being the bad guy if you don't give them a chance.
And he got a chance.
And the important thing here is he went from making these extremists rage bait,
fake news,
racist videos to like one of his latest videos was him wearing a wig and using a
bait purse that sprayed someone with milk,
like the most hokey,
PG 13 silly prank.
And I'm like,
there you go.
The videos he's making now are so mainstream and normal and Hokey,
he realized what he was doing was wrong.
What he said to me was he didn't realize how far he had gone.
He kept doing it and doing it and doing it was getting worse and he didn't
realize how bad it was getting.
And then,
you know,
it's only because he was able to come clean and people let him,
he did get banned from Youtube that now he's uh,
he's just,
uh,
like probably a normal conservative.
He makes silly videos.
Where would he be if he was banned?
He'd be hanging out on the dark corners of the web with the people who liked him
being fed,
constant negative and racist opinions.
And you are the summation of the people who surround you.
So that terrifies me.
And what's even worse,
as Jack said,
I fear that the darkness and I know it's happening and that's when I said the
snowflake doesn't blame itself.
All of these companies are doing it.
They are creating.
So the reason I bring this up right now is it may be early,
it may never happen,
but we are looking at the beginning with banks,
banning people with patriots,
with,
with social networks,
parallel networks,
emerging subscribe.
Stars are really good example.
This is the formation of a parallel economy where people are using foreign,
uh,
credit card processors now because the mains than the American ones won't do it.
Now you've got people who are completely on a separate economic system and they
can still interact for the time being.
But what happens when your credit card doesn't work anymore and you can't go to
any regular store.
So now you're,
you can only go to certain stores and these people aren't going to just die.
They're not going to give up on life.
They're going to say,
you people have kicked me out.
I don't like you.
You're my enemy.
You're gonna.
So,
so it looks like the pattern is obvious in my opinion.
If they don't stop,
you will at least end up with hundreds of thousands of people excise from
society if we're not already there.
And what happens when they say,
I want to have a rally.
They say,
oh,
these people are coming from Gab.
They must be neo.
So they show up with clubs and bats.
What are you allowed to do with Nazis?
Exactly.
And then these people come back.
So we've ever been guns to protect ourselves.
There was already a guy,
I think it was in Portland,
who when a bunch of protesters were marching towards him with his hands up and
drew his weapon on him.
He got charged.
He got in trouble.
But the,
here's the important takeaway on whether or not a civil war will happen when we
read history.
It's condensed.
We read in 1938,
the seven in 1939 this happened.
But for the people who lived it,
nothing happened six months later.
It was a slow,
gradual increase.
It may be in a hundred years that they say,
wow.
The second civil war,
civil war started on,
you know,
a 2016 after Trump got elected and,
uh,
the protestors showed up at his inauguration.
That was when it all started.
We're in it,
we can't see it.
We're in the forest,
you know,
we don't,
we don't realize so.
So we'll look,
I will give me negative,
positive,
negative,
positive.
There would be no,
it's all,
it's all negative.
What I mean to say it was a positive was that when you saw a guy like Joey
Salads you,
oh yeah,
yeah,
no,
no.
There are good people out there willing to,
the positive open up.
The positive when it comes to Joey is that he wasn't banned.
And so because he wasn't,
he said,
I'm going to do better and he did and now he's making these silly,
he makes some PG 13 videos where it's like,
you know,
pranks on my girlfriend and stuff.
But it's like so dramatically different from where he was getting out of
control.
And it's only because he was in band.
He was able to,
to become,
you know,
pulled back into the,
to the mainstream.
But if they just had to get rid of them,
you think that,
do you think he's gonna want to be homeless and starving?
He's going to try and figure out how to make money.
He's going to go on cryptocurrency.
He's going to go hang out with people who are willing to support him and he was
doing some stupid racist stuff.
So who do you think's going to support him?
We can't,
we can't have that.
We need to welcome people back into society and give them a chance to be part of
the mainstream and the norm.
I think we are seeing the gradual,
like it's,
it's,
it's likely,
in my opinion,
I think,
I think we,
we don't,
we don't realize we're in it.
We don't,
we don't realize we're in a forest.
We just see trees around us.
You know what I mean?
It'll be a damn shame because we will look back and for all the people that they
get so bad and we all hate each other and everything.
These are the good old days.
If that happens and I will do everything I can to make sure
criticism that I hear a lot from people is that when I first went on Rogan,
uh,
the first time and said that what's going on with Twitter as prop may maybe one
of the biggest problems we're facing today,
I saw comments from people who hate me who are like,
that's the stupidest thing.
Tim Pulls a moron.
He thinks Twitter's had important.
Kevin Hart lost hosting the Oscars because he tweeted something.
The Oscars are a major cultural event that was impacted because of one joke he
made on a platform.
So I think to myself,
maybe it is exaggerated and then I think to myself,
you know what it actually is.
I'll,
I'll give you another quick anecdote.
I was driving down a Roosevelt Avenue in Chicago,
going into the suburbs and I looked in my mirror and I saw a squad car and I
said,
Ooh,
I should get off the road right now.
He might pull me over.
Oh,
I'm being paranoid.
He then turns,
gets into the left turn lane,
puts his left signal on,
he pulled in front of me,
sped up,
and I thought to myself,
he wasn't going to pull me over.
Maybe I should get off the road.
That just in case nat,
he pulled me over.
So I thought from then I was like,
maybe if my intuition tells me that something's about to happen,
I should pay attention to that.
And I will say this too.
I,
I've been wrong about a few things.
Like I said,
I thought the Republicans going to sweep the midterms.
It was a bit mixed.
They took the Senate and um,
but I've consistently said we're going to see more violence.
Things are going to get worse.
And it's been,
it's been sporadic,
so I don't,
I don't know if I can say I'm right or wrong yet,
but I think with the people marching around with guns,
with,
you know,
the ever increasing escalation of violence,
we just had some proud boys plead guilty to the mob violence in New York.
Then it was like gang Vons or something.
I'm hoping it's not true.
Uh,
I don't know what the percentage would be if I was going to give it a
probability.
I lean.
I would just say this,
I believe it's a greater than chance.
We will have an escalation of civil conflict continually and I don't thinks
going to stop,
look when you,
when you,
uh,
I,
I was talking to my brother about this.
If you want to truly understand why you come to the point of sale of civil war
or conflict or insurgency,
I want you to go to one of these progressive leftists,
look them in the eye and say a biological male can never be biologically female
and they can't.
There is nothing in their brain that will ever comprehend that.
I've,
I have people from occupy Wall Street who are now posting on Facebook.
This guy said,
I can't believe people think male and female are objective things that exists.
I think these people are just stupid.
And so I sent him some research and I said,
look at these statistics.
Intersex is 1.7%.
That's from the intersects,
you know,
lobbying groups.
And he said,
I can't believe you actually think this is real.
You're,
you're crazy.
Or just stupid.
And I'm like,
if there is something as basic as I can actually look at a a man and a woman and
know which ones the men and woman,
I can't actually look at the earth being round without some special tool or
math.
Yeah.
These are the people that tell you that the conservatives don't believe in
science too.
Right?
And we
know the earth is round.
We can't see with our state,
with our eyes,
but we know it from our community and science.
I can look at a man and woman and tell you which one is which.
And not every case I,
I respect that.
But if you get to a point where there's someone who believes so fundamentally
that something that is real isn't what happens when it comes to,
when it comes to blows.
One of my favorite lines on this is Douglas Murray,
who I'm sure you're familiar with.
I asked him,
um,
you know,
what,
what does he,
how does he envision this sort of same question.
And he said,
you know,
one day the barbarians,
we'll be at the gate and we'll be debating what pronoun to call them.
Yeah.
That kind of gets there.
We'll listen if there's a,
literally,
if there's a little sliver of hope here,
I absolutely think you're part of it.
And then watching you grow through this whole freaking cold has been,
has been awesome.
So,
uh,
let's keep trying to fix this thing.
Right?
Why not?
Yeah.
I just don't know.
I just don't,
I'm not hopeful though.
After that conversation with Jack,
I'm like,
damn,
not hopeful.
Um,
it's,
it's nuance.
There's some things I think he listened to and maybe he'll do right,
but I really feel like all of his lieutenants are smug,
condescending,
arrogant.
We know what's right.
We're going to do it anyway.
I'm like,
welcome to the tyranny.
It's the end for more rip Tim Pool.
It's just slashed him cast,
uh,
on Youtube.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yes.
It's youtube.com/tim cast and you're going to get a new beat any one of these
days.
I actually know this isn't,
this is that one is new.
Yeah.
It's not saying when I have just a bunch of different ones.
Similar style,
different companies.
It depends on the color of shirts I'm wearing,
you know,
catch all the beanies and all the truth at youtube.com/tim cast.
All right.
Thanks guys.